THANK YOU GOOD MORNING EVERYBODY --
WE WANT.
TO JUST THANK EVERYBODY FOR
COMING TODAY TO OUR ASSEMBLY
SELECT COMMITTEE ON AGING
CALIFORNIA TRADE AND INVESTMENT --
WE ALSO WANTED TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE ON JOBS ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND THE ECONOMY FOR
TWENTY HOSTED THIS YEAR WE HAVE.
TONY SIMONS HERE WHO'S THE
CONSULTANT FROM THE COMMITTEE
BUT ALSO WANT TO THANK THEM THEY
ARE THE ONES WHO ARE PRIMARILY
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE REPORT THAT
YOU SEE -- PRODUCE REALLY
TALKING ABOUT.
THE SITUATION IN THE IMPACT OF
THE U. S. CHINA TERRACE ON OUR
ECONOMY -- THIS IS THE FAST
SIXTY YEAR I'VE BEEN CHAIRING
THIS ASSEMBLY SUBCOMMITTEE AT
THE SELECT COMMITTEE.
AND REALLY -- BUT THE HOPE OF
THIS SELECT COMMITTEE WAS TO BE
IDENTIFIED IN TO TALK ABOUT.
THE VERY IMPORTANT RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN CALIFORNIA AND ALL THE
VARIOUS ASIA TRADING PARTNERS --
OBVIOUSLY IN A IS ONE OF THOSE
MAJOR TRADING PARTNERS
FORTUNATELY -- STARTING IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN WE'VE BEEN IN A
TRADE WAR WHERE THE UNITED
STATES HAS -- PATEROS ON A
VARIETY OF CHINESE GOOD OVER
OVER THAT TIME ALMOST MORE THAN
EIGHT HUNDRED CHINESE GOODS AND
THEN.
CHINA HAS THEN FOR RETALIATED
PRIMARILY ON AGRICULTURAL GOODS
WHICH IS HAD A NEGATIVE IMPACT
ON CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY WHAT
REALLY WHAT WE'VE SEEN.
IS CALIFORNIA.
HE IS A HUGE IN CHINA AS A HUGE
ANY PARTNER FOR CALIFORNIA IT'S
OUR THIRD LARGEST TRADING
PARTNER AFTER CANADA AND MEXICO --
IT'S WE EXPORT NEARLY THREE
POINT EIGHT BILLION GOODS TO
CHINA -- AND AGAIN MOST OF THOSE
EXPORTS ARE NOT FROM LARGE
COMPANIES ARE FROM SMALL
COMPANIES 96% OF ALL K. TWENTY
EXPORTS COME FROM SMALL AND
MEDIUM SIZED.
COMPANIES UNFORTUNATELY SINCE
THE TERRORISTS HAVE GONE INTO
EFFECT WAS SEEN -- SOME NEGATIVE
IMPACT THE PORTAL THE SENTENCES
ON THAT EXPORTS TO CHINA HAVE
DECREASED BY 25%.
IN DATA FROM THE US CENSUS
BUREAU HAS SAID THAT THE VALUE
OF CHINESE EXPORTS.
CALIFORNIA'S PUSH TO CHINA HAS
PLEASE BY A BILLION TO BUY
BILLION DOLLARS FROM TWENTY
SEVENTEEN TO TWENTY EIGHTEEN
ALONE.
SO AGAIN WHAT WE SEE IS A VERY --
SHORT TERM NEGATIVE IMPACT ON
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY IN
PARTICULAR AGRICULTURAL GOODS
HAD BEEN.
HIT THE HARDEST -- WE SAW
THERE'S A 25% DECREASE IN WINE
EXPORTS FROM THE US [INAUDIBLE]
TO CHINA.
WITH. 90% OF THOSE EXPORTS BEING
FROM OFF.
SO WE KNOW THAT THE AGRICULTURE.
IN THE WINE INDUSTRY ARE REALLY
GETTING HIT THE HARDEST.
SO TODAY'S HEARING IS REALLY TO
TALK ABOUT.
WHAT CALIFORNIA CAN CONTINUE TO
DO CALIFORNIA WANTS TO CONTINUE
TO HAVE A?
VERY STRONG ECONOMIC
RELATIONSHIP WITH CHINA.
WE CONTINUE TO MAINTAIN A VERY
OPEN RELATIONSHIP TO CONTINUE
WANTED.
TO FIGURE OUT WHAT WE COULD DO A
POSITIVELY IN LIGHT OF WHAT'S
GOING ON BETWEEN OUR TWO
COUNTRIES.
AGAIN I I WERE STARTED EARLIER
BY SAYING NINE IS OUR THIRD
LARGEST TRADING PARTNER -- WE
KNOW THAT CONSUMERS ARE IMPACTED
BY THESE DOES BECAUSE CONSIDER
BUYING BETTER IMPLEMENTED IN
FROM CHINA ARE MORE EXPENSIVE.
AND THEN WE ALSO SEE THE
CONTINUED THE CONCERN ABOUT THE
LOSS OF POTENTIAL JOBS
ESPECIALLY IN THAT HARBOR
CULTURE INDUSTRY.
I'M VERY HONORED HONORED TO BE
JOINED BY OUR LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR A LADY COULD UNLOCK THE
SUIT TODAY IS ARE ACTING
GOVERNOR BECAUSE OUR GOVERNOR IS
OUT OF TOWN.
SO I DON'T KNOW IF THERE'S ANY
KIND OF PROCLAMATIONS THERE.
ARE CERTAIN ACTIONS TO TAKE
TODAY REALLY -- I'M VERY HONORED
THAT HE'S HERE SHE IS -- REALLY
GOING TO BE TAKING THE LEAD FOR
OUR STATE.
ON MARCH.
KNOW HOW TRADE AND INVESTMENT
WILL BE WORKING AS WELL AS OUR
RELATIONSHIPS WITH ALL OUR TREES
SO I JUST WANTED.
TO TURN OVER TO OUR LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR.
SORRY THANK YOU SO MUCH AS SOME
REMEMBER TING IT'S GREAT TO BE
HERE.
AND THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO APPEAR BEFORE YOU
TODAY TO ADDRESS THE IMPACTS TO
CALIFORNIA.
FROM.
CHANGING FEDERAL TRADE POLICIES.
AND THE DISPUTE WITH CHINA.
I'D LIKE TO START BY NOTING THAT
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT OF THE
UNITED STATES AND THE U. S.
CONGRESS HAVE THE EXCLUSIVE
JURISDICTION TO STEP TRADE
POLICY FOR THE NATION.
UNDER ARTICLE ONE OF THE US
CONSTITUTION.
BECAUSE OF THE SIZE OF THE
CALIFORNIA ECONOMY AND OUR INTER
DEPENDENCE ON FOREIGN TRADE
FEDERAL TRADE POLICY IMPACTS
CALIFORNIA DISPROPORTIONATELY TO
OTHER STATES.
THAT'S WHY THIS HEARING IS SO
IMPORTANT BY ENTERING INTO THE
PUBLIC RECORD TESTIMONY FROM
EXPERTS AND STAKEHOLDERS HERE
TODAY.
THE GENERAL PUBLIC AND THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WILL HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HEAR ABOUT THE
IMPACTS OF THE TERROR.
BE WITH CHINA ON OUR STREETS
ECONOMY AND THE CONCERNS THAT
STAKEHOLDERS ARE EXPRESSING.
AS YOU ARE WELL AWARE THE TEST
IS WITH CHINA INITIATED BY THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
HAS BEEN DEEPLY DISRUPTIVE TO
STATE CALLED ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
A LARGE PART OF THE DISRUPTION
HAS BEEN CAUSED BY THE WAY THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS BEEN
CONDUCTING ITSELF.
PRESIDENT TRUMP REGULARLY USES
TWITTER TO ANNOUNCE OR
THREATENED TARIFFS WHICH HE
SOMETIMES FOLLOWS THROUGH ONE
AND SOMETIMES DOESN'T.
THE UNCERTAINTY OF THIS PROCESS
ALONE HAS CAST A DARK SHADOW ON
THE RELIABILITY OF U. S.
PRODUCTS AS PART.
OF GLOBAL SUPPLY CHANGE ACROSS
INDUSTRIES.
I'D ALSO LIKE TO SAY UP FRONT
THAT ALTHOUGH DONALD TRUMP
REGULARLY STATES THAT CHINA IS
PAYING THE TERRACE HE HAS
IMPOSED.
IT IS ACTUALLY AMERICAN
CONSUMERS WHO ARE PAYING THE
PRICE AND SO FAR PAYING DEARLY.
SO I'D LIKE TO START THIS
MORNING'S PRESENTATION BY GOING
THROUGH A BRIEF TIMELINE OF
MAJOR EVENTS SO FAR IN THE
ESCALATING TRADE DISPUTE.
JUST TO HELP ESTABLISH A
FRAMEWORK FOR TODAY'S HEARING.
THE FIRST SOUND THAT WAS BACK IN
MARCH OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN WHEN
THE ADMINISTRATION IMPOSED A 25%
TARIFF.
ON IMPORTED STEEL AND 10% TARIFF
ON IMPORTED ALUMINUM HE CLAIMED
TO BE TO DO SO UNDER SECTION TWO
THIRTY TWO OF THE TRADE
EXPANSION ACT OF NINETEEN SIXTY
TWO SECTION TWO THIRTY TO
ESTABLISH AS THE POWER OF THE
PRESIDENT TO LEVY TARIFFS.
ON THE GROUNDS OF NATIONAL
SECURITY.
IN OTHER WORDS PRESIDENT TRUMP
CLAIMED THAT STEEL AND ALUMINUM
IMPORTS NOT JUST IN CHINA BUT
FROM THE EUROPEAN UNION AND
CANADA AND MEXICO.
POST A CREDIBLE SECURITY THREAT
TO OUR COUNTRY.
THE TWO THIRTY TWO TERMS BECAUSE
THE PRICE OF ALUMINUM AND STEEL
IN THE U. S. TO SEARCH AND HAD
NO IMMEDIATE IMPACT ON
CALIFORNIA'S CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRY AS WELL AS OUR
AEROSPACE INDUSTRY.
ACCORDING TO THE PETERSON
INSTITUTE TWO THIRTY TWO TERRACE
INCREASE THE PRICE OF STEEL IN
THE U. S. BY ABOUT 10%.
THAT'S ABOUT AN ELEVEN AND A
HALF BILLION DOLLAR PER YEAR
COST TO THE US ECONOMY.
ON MAY NINETEENTH AFTER FOURTEEN
MONTHS IN PLACE THE
ADMINISTRATION GAVE EXEMPTIONS
TO MEXICO AND CANADA AS PART OF
NEGOTIATIONS OVER US MCA.
THE TRADE AGREEMENT WHICH IF
ADOPTED WILL REPLACE NAFTA. TWO
THIRTY TWO STEPS.
STEEL AND ALUMINUM HOWEVER ARE
STILL IN PLACE FOR CHINA.
AND THE PRICE OF STEEL IN THE US
HAS NOT COME DOWN ON IN SPITE OF
THE EXEMPTIONS FOR CANADA AND
MEXICO.
THE TWO THIRTY TWO TERMS ARE
ALSO INCIDENTALLY STILL IN PLACE
FOR IMPORTS FROM THE EUROPEAN
UNION I ROB LIKE OF COURSE SINCE
THE E. U. IS HOME TO MOST OF OUR
NATO ALLIES.
SO TWO MONTHS AFTER THE TWO
THIRTY TWO TAPS WERE IMPOSED IN
MAY.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE TRADE
DISPUTE WITH CHINA RAMPED UP
WITH THE IMPOSITION OF SECTION
THREE A ONE TERRACE.
SECTION THREE A ONE OF THE US
TRADE ACT NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR
AUTHORIZES THE PRESIDENT TO TAKE
ALL APPROPRIATE ACTION INCLUDING
RETALIATION. TO OBTAIN THE
REMOVAL OF ANY ACT POLICY OR
PRACTICE.
OF A FOREIGN GOVERNMENT THAT IS
UNJUSTIFIED UNREASONABLE BUT
DISCRIMINATORY AND THE BURDENS
OR RESTRICTS US COMMERCE.
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND TWENTY
EIGHTEEN SECTION THREE ARE ONE
INVESTIGATIONS DETERMINED THE
CHILD.
HAD REPEATEDLY VIOLATED THESE
PROVISIONS US COMPANIES
ATTEMPTING TO DO BUSINESS IN
CHINA HAVE LONG REPORTED
INSTANCES OF INTELLECTUAL
PROPERTY THREAT STAFFED FORCE
JOINT VENTURES AND THE FAILURE
TO LIVE UP TO AGREEMENTS.
AND THEIR ENFORCEMENT SO LET ME
JUST A FARM THE CHINA SECTION
THREE ARE ONE VIOLATION.
ALL REAL AND THEY ARE SERIOUS
BUT WHILE THERE IS LITTLE
DISPUTE ABOUT THE SERIOUSNESS OF
THE VIOLATIONS THERE IS A GREAT
DEAL OF CONCERN.
OVER HOW THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
MOVED FORWARD IN ADDRESSING THAT.
IN JULY OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE
US POST A 25% IMPORT TERRA ON
THREE FOUR BILLION DOLLARS AND
IMPORTS CHINESE CUTS.
CHINA IMMEDIATELY RETALIATED
WITH TARIFFS ON US IMPORTS THE
SAME AMOUNT.
A MONTH LATER THE US IMPOSED A
25% TARIFF ON CONDITIONAL
SIXTEEN BILLION DOLLARS OF
IMPORTS FROM CHINA.
AND CHINA IMMEDIATELY RETALIATED
WITH TARIFFS ON US EXPORTS IN
THE SAME AMOUNT.
ON SEPTEMBER TWENTY FOURTH.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN IN RESPONSE TO
CHINA'S HOW YOU TORIE TERRACE
THE US IMPOSED A 10% IMPORT
TARIFF ON APPROXIMATELY TWO
HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS WORTH OF
CHINESE CUTS.
INCLUDING MANY EVERY DAY
CONSERVE OUR PRODUCTS LIKE IT'S
ELECTRONICS AND HOUSEWARES.
CHINA AGAIN RETALIATED WITH
TERRACE ON ANOTHER SIXTY BILLION
DOLLARS OF AMERICAN MADE
PRODUCTS.
IN DECEMBER PRESIDENT TRUMP
ANNOUNCED -- NEGOTIATIONS WITH
CHINA AND CLEARED THE SEPTEMBER
TWENTY FOURTH S. WILL REMAIN AT
10% RATHER THAN INCREASING 225%
CREATING A PARTIAL REPRIEVE.
IN MAY TWENTY NINETEEN SO JUST
ABOUT TWO MONTHS AGO THE
PRESIDENT TWEETED THAT
NEGOTIATIONS WERE MOVING TOO
SLOWLY.
AND THE US INCREASED TERRACE.
TWO HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS IN
CHINESE GOODS FROM 10% 225%.
AS I NOTED AT THE START IT IS
AMERICAN CONSUMERS WHO ARE
PAYING THE PRICE OF THESE
TERRORISTS NOT CHINA.
AND THE IMPACT OF TERRACE UP TO
THIS POINT IS ESTIMATED AT
APPROXIMATELY FOUR HUNDRED
NINETEEN DOLLARS IN INCREASED
COSTS FOR THE AVERAGE AMERICAN
HOUSEHOLD.
SOON AFTER TRUMP ANNOUNCED THAT
HE IS NOW CONSIDERING A TERROR
525%. ONE IT'S IMPORTED FROM
CHINA WHICH HAD NOT UP TO THIS
POINT IN IMPACTED.
THESE RECORDS TO A STAGE FOR
TERROR.
THEY ARE MOSTLY CONSUMER
ELECTRONIC PRODUCTS AND OUR
ESTIMATED AT ABOUT THREE HUNDRED
AND TWENTY FIVE BILLION DOLLARS.
AT LAST MONTH'S G. TWENTY SUMMIT
IN TOKYO CHINESE PRESIDENT XI
CHING PAYING AND PRESIDENT TROP
MATT.
AND AGREE TO SEND THEIR TEAMS
BACK TO THE NEGOTIATING TABLE.
THIS IS GOOD NEWS AND ALTHOUGH
THERE WAS NO CONCRETE AGREEMENT
TRUMP ANNOUNCED THAT HE WOULD
HOLD OFF ON THE IMPOSITION.
OF STAGE FOR TERRA AT LEAST FOR
NOW.
SO TODAY AS WE WAIT FOR THE NEXT
ROUND OF ACTIVITY HERE IS WHAT
WE NOW. 232- AND THREE OH ONE
TERRACE TINIEST CUTS AND THE
RETALIATORY TARIFFS IMPOSED BY
CHINA.
ARE IN PLACE THEY ARE HAVING
SERIOUS IMPACTS ON THE
CALIFORNIA ECONOMY.
AND THEY'RE NOT LIKELY TO GO
AWAY ANYTIME SOON.
MEANWHILE THE THRESHOLD
RATIONALE FOR THE THREE OH ONE
WAS TO CREATE PRESSURE ON CHINA
TO MAKE MEANINGFUL CHANGES TO
ADDRESS THREE OH ONE VIOLATIONS.
AND ABSOLUTELY NO PROGRESS
WHATSOEVER HAS BEEN MADE ON
ISSUES SURROUNDING CHINA'S
BUSINESS PRACTICES.
THIS IS ESPECIALLY WORRISOME FOR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AS THE WORLD'S FIFTH LARGEST
ECONOMY CALIFORNIA IS DEEPLY
INTEGRATED INTO THE GLOBAL
MARKETS AND SUPPLY CHAINS.
OUR STATE RELIES ON OVER SIX
HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS WORTH OF
TRADE EVERY YEAR.
CALIFORNIA IS NUMBER ONE IN THE
COUNTRY IN AGRICULTURAL EXPORTS.
AND IN EXPORTS OF MACHINERY AND
ELECTRONICS WE ALSO FIRST IN THE
COUNTRY IN COMBINED GOODS AND
SERVICES EXPORTS AND IMPORTS.
CALIFORNIA'S TRADE
INFRASTRUCTURE IS EXTENSIVE WE
HAVE ELEVEN PORTS AND TWELVE
INTERNATIONAL AIRPORT ROUTE THE
STATE. THIRTEEN IF WE CAP
TIJUANA WHICH IS CONNECTED TO
SAN DIEGO VTC C. BACKS.
THE LOS ANGELES THE LONG BEACH
PORT COMPLEX IS THE NATION'S
LARGEST CONTAINER PORT.
IN EVERY DAY ABOUT ONE BILLION
DOLLARS WORTH OF GOODS COMING IN
THROUGH ITS STOCKS.
LOGISTICS FREIGHT WHERE HOUSING
AND HE COMMERCE INDUSTRIES HAVE
DEVELOPED AROUND CALIFORNIA'S
INTERNATIONAL TRADE WITH HIS
SCALE THAT IS UNMATCHED ANYWHERE
IN THE COUNTRY.
RATE SUPPORTS ENTIRE SUPPLY
CHAINS AND HIGHER WAGES FOR
WORKERS THROUGHOUT THE SUPPLY
CHAINS.
MANY CALIFORNIANS LIVELY BUT ARE
TIED TO THE GOODS MOVEMENT
INDUSTRY AND MORE BROADLY AN
ESTIMATED 20% OF ALL THE JOBS IN
STATE ARE DEPENDENT ON
INTERNATIONAL TRADE AND
INVESTMENT.
THAT'S ABOUT FIVE POINT FOUR
MILLION CALIFORNIA JOBS.
AND THESE ARE GOOD MIDDLE CLASS
JOBS DOCKWORKERS WAREHOUSE
WORKERS WELL WORKERS TRUCK
DRIVERS BOAT CRUISE TRADE
SPECIALISTS AND RETAILERS.
IF THAT GOODS MOVEMENT FORCE
THESE ARE ALL EXAMPLES OF TRADE
SUPPORTING NO CLASS CALIFORNIA
JOBS WITH DECENT WAGES.
SO CALIFORNIA HAS A GREAT DEAL
AT STAKE AND WE ARE ALREADY
FEELING THE IMPACTS OF THE US
CHINA TERRACE DISPUTE.
THE US CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
ESTIMATED THAT OVER THIRTEEN
BILLION DOLLARS OF CALIFORNIA
EXPORTS THREATENED BY THE
TERRORISTS.
EXPORTS TO CHINA FROM CALIFORNIA
PORTS WERE DOWN 9% YEAR TO DATE.
TWENTY NINETEEN COMPARED TO THE
FIRST FIVE MONTHS OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN OUR COLLEAGUES FROM THE
PORT OF LONG BEACH TOLD US THAT
IN MAY OF THIS YEAR.
CAN TRAIN CONTAINER TRADE WITH
CHINA BOTH IMPORTS AND EXPORTS
WAS DOWN BY 18% FROM THE SAME
MONTH ONE YEAR EARLIER.
ASSEMBLYMAN TANG I THINK THAT
YOU ACTUALLY JUST AT RELATE SOME
UPDATED INFORMATION AROUND THE
SAME NUMBERS.
JOBS CONNECTED TO INTERNATIONAL
TRADE AREN'T JUST ALONG THE
COAST BUT IN INLAND AREAS OF
CALIFORNIA AS WELL.
RURAL AREAS OF THE STATE
SUFFERING DISPROPORTIONATELY AS
RURAL INDUSTRIES AGRICULTURE AND
THE CHEST X. HAVE SIGNIFICANT
EXPOSURE TO CHANGES IN THE TRADE
FOR SHE CALIFORNIA HAS OVER FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND AGRICULTURAL
JOBS. 70% OF WHICH ARE IN RURAL
AREAS THE INLAND EMPIRE NOW HOST
AND MAJOR LOGISTICS AND
DISTRIBUTION CLUSTER.
DRIVING ALONG I..
FIVE SEE DOZENS OF LARGE
DISTRIBUTION CENTERS NEARLY ALL
OF WHICH HAVE TRADE SUPPORTER
JOBS.
IMPORTANT CALIFORNIA CROP CROPS
HAVE BEEN KEY TARGETS PINE AS
RETALIATORY TARIFFS AND THE
EFFECTS CONTINUE [INAUDIBLE]
THIS.
MIKE CAL MAG.
I DON'T KNOW HOW THIS ENDED UP
HEREBY APPROVE.
IMPORTANT CALIFORNIA CROPS HAVE
BEEN KEY TARGETS CHINA'S
RETALIATORY TARIFFS AND THE
EFFECTS CONTINUE.
CONSIDER THE CASE OF ALMONDS.
CALIFORNIA SUPPLIES 82% OF THE
WORLD'S ALMONDS AND IT'S ALMOST
SEVEN THOUSAND GROWERS.
ALMONDS ARE ONE OF CALIFORNIA'S
TOP EXPORT COMMODITIES THE
ALLMAN BOARD OF CALIFORNIA
ESTIMATES THE INDUSTRY GENERATES
ABOUT A HUNDRED AND FOUR
THOUSAND JOBS IN THE STATE.
CHINA IMPOSED 50% TARIFFS ON US
OPENS IN THE ESCALATING TRADE
WAR.
JULIE ADAMS WITH THE ALLMAN
BOARD OF CALIFORNIA.
SAID YOU SEE THE SIGNIFICANT
IMPACT SINCE THE TERRORISTS WERE
INTRODUCED LAST YEAR.
SHE SAID THE FOR DECADES THE
ALLMAN BOARD HAS BEEN MARKETING
IN CHINA.
TRYING TO RAISE AWARENESS ABOUT
ALMONDS IN COOKING AND AS A
SNACK.
SINCE THE INTRODUCTION OF THE
TERRORIST EXPORTS TO CHINA.
INCREASED BY ABOUT ONE THIRD.
ACCORDING TO THE HARMON BOARD.
AND IT'S NOT AS THOUGH OTHER
COUNTRIES ARE SITTING IDLY BY.
STRESS HAS A FREE TRADE
AGREEMENT WITH CHINA PROVIDING
THE COUNTRY THE OPPORTUNITY TO
REPLACE CALIFORNIA ALMONDS THAT
NOW CARRY TERRACE.
THE AUSTRALIAN ALMOND BOARD
REPORTED AN 88% INCREASE IN
EXPORTS TO CHINA FROM BETWEEN.
TWENTY SIXTEEN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NOW TRUMP HAS ANNOUNCED A
SIXTEEN BILLION DOLLAR AID
PACKAGE FOR YOU -- FARMERS
WHO'VE BEEN HURT BY THE CARRIAGE
DISPUTE IT WAS INITIALLY
DESIGNED PRIMARILY TO HELP
FARMERS IN MIDWESTERN STATES.
ALTHOUGH THE PACKAGE HAS BEEN
REVISED TO INCLUDE MORE
CALIFORNIA GROWN CROPS.
THE CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION PRESIDENT CHENEY
JOHANNSEN RIGHTFULLY SAID.
THAT THE LAST ASSISTANCE TO
FARMERS AND RANCHERS WOULD BE TO
RESOLVE THE TRADE DISPUTES AND
RE OPEN MARKETS FOR CALIFORNIA
FARM PRODUCTS.
BOB ALSO WORKING TO COPE WITH
HOW THEIR OPERATIONS ARE BEING
FINANCIALLY IMPACTED.
THE LOS ANGELES TIMES RECENTLY
REPORTED THAT SOME FARMERS MAY
NEED TO TAKE ON MORE OF THE
SHIPPING COSTS TO MAKE UP THE
INCREASE PRICES.
WORST MAY ALSO CUT DOWN ON
SPENDING ON EQUIPMENT AND
FERTILIZER PERHAPS TO MAKING THE
CHOICE TO GO REPLACING A TRACK --
OTHER BIG TICKET ITEMS.
AS BECAUSE THE INVENTORY TO SLOW
IT IS ALSO STRETCH THE CAPACITY
A STORAGE FACILITY.
THE EFFECT OF THE TRADE AND
TERRACE DISPUTE WITH CHINA IS
ALSO DISPROPORTIONATELY OUT BY
CALIFORNIA SMALL AND MEDIUM
SIZED BUSINESSES.
ACCORDING TO THE SMALL BUSINESS
ADMINISTRATION OVER SEVENTY
THOUSAND SMALL BUSINESSES AND
FOR ANYA ARE GAUGE IN EXPERTS.
AS A JUST A FEW YEARS AGO SMALL
BUSINESSES WILL SPONSOR FOR OVER
95% OF THE GOODS EXPORTED FROM
CALIFORNIA.
DESPITE THE OUTSIZE ROLE
CALIFORNIA SMALL AND MEDIUM
SIZED BUSINESSES HEY IN THE
STATE'S INTERNATIONAL TRADE.
THEY DO NOT HAVE THE SAME
RESOURCES AS LARGE COMPANIES TO
SHIP THEIR SUPPLY CHAIN OR FIND
NEW INTERNATIONAL CUSTOMERS TO
MAKE UP FOR LOST BUSINESS.
THE US CHAMBER OF COMMERCE BASIS
AB BASES OF TRADE CAMPAIGN
FEATURES STORIES CALIFORNIA
BUSINESSES IMPACTED BY THE
TERRORISTS.
AND I'D LIKE TO SHARE A FEW.
SAUL CAM WHO OWNS AND OPERATES
ITS WE PHAM ORGANICS LÀ MARANDA.
IMPORT EXPORT FOOD AND STOPS TO
AND FROM CHINA.
MR CAM REPORTED THAT HIS
COMPANIES ALREADY OPERATING ON
VERY SMALL MARGIN.
THE FINANCIAL IMPACT OF THE
TERRACE MEANS THAT HIS BUSINESS
WILL ESSENTIALLY BE SHOT DOWN.
MR K. PORTS THAT HIS EMPLOYEES
NO JOBS I TRIED TO THE TO THE
TRADE DISPUTES.
AND IT IS VERY SAD REALITY FOR
MR CAM AND HIS WORKERS.
CHAD MAKE ANY OF SAN DIEGO
FOUNDED A COMPANY CALLED DRY
START A BUSINESS THE DEVELOPS.
TAX.
CHAD TESTED NEARLY SIXTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS OF HIS OWN
SAVINGS TO HELP FOUND THE
COMPANY.
AND HE SPENT FROM INSPECTING
CHINESE FACTORIES AND
ESTABLISHING RELATIONSHIPS WITH
CHINESE MANUFACTURER. TO
FINALIZE PRODUCTION OF HIS
SURFBOARD BACKS.
WHAT'S MORE CHAD COMPANY IS
DEDICATED TO SUPPORTING CHARTER
ENTERPRISES WITH THEIR PROFIT.
BUT DESPITE STRONG PRE CELL
NUMBERS FOR TRY START SUPPORT
BACKS CHATS COMPANY IS HAVING A
HARD TIME STAYING AFLOAT.
THANKS TO THE TERRORISTS.
SMALL COMPANIES LIKE WE FARM AND
TRY START STRUGGLING GIVEN THE
EFFECTIVE TAX HEAD ON THEIR
PRODUCTS WE SHOULD EXPECT TO HER
MANY MORE STORIES LIKE THESE.
SO LONG AS THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION'S TRADE POLICIES
CAN YOU ON THIS TRACK.
IT IS ALSO IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT ONCE GLOBAL SUPPLY CHAINS
ARE JUST WRAPPED IT.
IT IS VERY HARD TO GET THEM. FOR
EXAMPLE LAST YEAR CALIFORNIA
WINE EXPORTS TO CHINA FELL
NEARLY 25% AFTER TAXES AND
TARIFFS ON US WINE ENTERING
CHINA REACHED NEARLY. 80%.
DEMAND HAS QUICKLY BEEN ABSORBED
INCREASED EXPORTS FROM CHILE AND
AUSTRALIA THAT IT'S IN THEIR
WINE EXPORTS TO CHINA SEARCH.
LET ME SAY FOR THE RECORD THEIR
WINE IS NOT AS GOOD AS
CALIFORNIA.
ONE FINALLY THESE TERRORISTS ARE
IMPACTING OUR ABILITY TO MEET
OTHER CHALLENGES WE FACE IN THIS
STATE.
CALIFORNIA IS IN THE MIDST OF A
MAJOR HOUSING CRISIS AND THE
TERRORISTS HAVE HIT THE
HOMEBUILDING INDUSTRY HEART.
ACCORDING TO SOME ESTIMATES.
ALREADY ADDED ONE BILLION
DOLLARS TO THE COST OF US
HOUSING CONSTRUCTION.
SO IN CONCLUSION.
IT IS VERY POSSIBLE THAT WE WILL.
SEE AN END TO THESE TRADE
DISPUTES ANYTIME SOON.
AND OUR STATE MUST PREPARE FOR
PROLONGED IMPACTS.
NOW THAT THE PROCEDURE HAS GONE
TO TAKE ACTION AGAINST CHINA ON
THREE OH ONE VIOLATIONS.
THERE WAS BIPARTISAN CONSENSUS
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION SHOULD
NOT LEAVE THE NEGOTIATING TABLE
AND TELL THERE IS MEANINGFUL
RESOLUTION OF THE ORIGINAL
VIOLATIONS BY CHINA.
BUT EVEN LEVEL OF COMPLEXITY
INVOLVED AND CHINA'S RECENT
SIGNALS THAT THEY ARE NOT
WILLING TO BET ON SOME KEY
PROVISIONS.
THIS COULD TAKE A LONG TIME.
AND THE TIME IT TAKES FOR THESE
ISSUES TO RESOLVE MEANS MORE
MONEY COMING OUT OF CALIFORNIA
POCKETS.
A STUDY EARLIER THIS YEAR AS I
MENTIONED BEFORE FOUND THAT THE
IMPACT OF THE TERRORIST BUT
REQUIRE A FAMILY OF FOUR TO FIND
AN ADDITIONAL FOUR HUNDRED
NINETEEN DOLLARS A YEAR. TO PAY
FOR INCREASED COSTS OF CURRENT.
THAT'S MONEY THE CALIFORNIA
FAMILIES CAN BETTER SPENT
ELSEWHERE.
AND OF COURSE THE IMPACTS TO
CALIFORNIA COMPANIES ATTEMPTING
TO STAY AFLOAT AND CONTINUE TO
IMPORT TO CHINA.
IN THIS CURRENT ENVIRONMENT IS
VERY VERY SERIOUS.
SO WITH THAT I WILL CONCLUDE MY
REMARKS AND I AM HAPPY TO TAKE
ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU MIGHT
HAVE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF IT WE'RE
HOPING TO DO IS.
YEAH EVERYBODY SPEAK AND THEN WE
CAN HAVE A LITTLE.
DIALOGUE ON THE ISSUE -- BUT
REALLY APPRECIATE THEM THE
GOVERNOR FROM MUCH HIGHLIGHTING
THE IMPACT ON CALIFORNIA.
AND I I BELIEVE HIGHLAND PARK IN
PARTICULAR ARE SMALL BUSINESSES
THE P. TO BUSINESSES THAT REALLY.
ARE THE ONES THAT ARE THE
BACKBONE OF OUR ECONOMY SO THANK
YOU.
NEXT WE VERY HONORED TO HAVE A
DEPUTY CONSUL GENERAL RUN FIVE
CHEN -- FROM THE PEOPLE'S
REPUBLIC OF CHINA HERE.
TO TALK ABOUT THE IMPACT OF THIS
TRADE WAR THANK YOU [INAUDIBLE]
KILL.
THANK YOU EVERYBODY THANK HILL
[INAUDIBLE]
HONORABLE.
THEN UNDER LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR.
I 1100% AGREE WITH YOU -- I
MYSELF THE FAN CALIFORNIA ONE
AND THE FRUIT.
THIS BETTER NOT AUSTRALIA AND
CHILE.
I KNOW WE WANT TO WORK WITH YOU
TO GATHERED TOO LITTLE. TOO
LITTLE DOWN THE TARIFFS 22%.
YEAH THAT'S ALTHOUGH WE SHARE
THE SAME GO.
ON ABOUT LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR
STAND [INAUDIBLE]
TO ASSEMBLYMEMBER. FIFTEEN AND
IS GOOD MORNING EVERYBODY.
IT'S A BEAUTIFUL DAY THE SUN
SHINING OUTSIDE.
THANK YOU WILL WE FOUND SO MANY
FRIENDS OUTSIDE -- TO SAN
FRANCISCO -- MAIL FLOW.
MERETE MY FRIEND IT'S AN AND
ALSO.
FROM SACRAMENTO -- TONY.
AND THE AGENDA YOU APPROACH TO
THE SUNNY -- TO THE FOR THE CITY.
OF SAN FRANCISCO.
I'M THE I HOPE AND IT IS OUR
DESIGNS THAT WE WANT TO STATE
SOME SHINING TO OUR BETTER
RELATIONS SIX SPECIALLY.
TREATED TO END OF THE CABLE SO
THAT TO BE THERE'S A NOTE --
DOCTOR CRAWLED TO STOLE FOR A
THREAD OF TARIFFS AND TRADE
TREATABLE WE SHOULD PUT AN END
TO TREAT WHAT LET'S WORK
TOGETHER.
THIS YEAR MARKS THE FORTIETH
ANNIVERSARY -- FOR US CHINA
RELATIONS ALSO THE FORTIES ON
WERE THREE OF THE FUNDING ALL
PHILLIP PENNIES CONSULATE
GENERAL.
HERE.
OVER THE PAST FORTY YEARS.
ALTHOUGH THE OPTIONS UPS AND THE
DOWNS PRISON TURNS OUT BETTER TO
READ IT AND SO THANKS TO ALL OF
THE EFFORTS OF BOTH SIDES OF
LEADERS THAT BUSINESS.
PEOPLE SAID THAT ON THE ORDINARY
PEOPLE.
ALL OF THAT ACTUAL LESIONS MAKE
REMARKABLE PROGRESS AND BENEFIT
BOTH OF PEOPLE ON THE REST OF
THE STUFF THE WORLD.
THE BETTER TREAT [INAUDIBLE]
BEGIN FROM. TWENTY FOUR POINT
FIVE BEATING LAST ORDER IN.
NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE AFTER
FORTY YEARS INCREASE THE BY. TWO
HUNDRED AND SIXTY TIMES. TOO SIX
HUNDRED IN THE SEARCH A SURVEY
ON THE FIGHT BILLION US TO ORDER.
OF COURSE THE AS THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
MENTIONED.
CHINA ENJOYING TRADE SURPLUS BUT
THE INSIDE THE TRIP SURPLUS.
HOP ALL FOR THE EXPORT THE
PRODUCT.
IS THE PRODUCT -- PRODUCE THINGS.
FACTORIES THE NY STATED OF FOR
YOU WHY STATE.
FACTORIES IN CHINA AND AMONG
THOSE.
OFF FROM U. S. INVESTORS. TO THE
SERVICE TRADE AT THE LESS IN
DORNE.
SURPLUS.
OUR SURVEYS TRADER GROW
[INAUDIBLE]
FROM THE EARLIEST. ZERO TWO
SEVEN FIVE BILLION US DOLLARS.
IN THE YEAR OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN
ON U. S. EXPORT OF SERVICE TO
CHINA WILL MORE THAN FIFTY SEVEN
POINT. SIX BILLION US DOLLARS.
TODAY CHINA AND A IS THE US
CERTAIN LARGEST.
TRADING PARTNER.
SEARCH LOUDEST TO EXPORT MARKET
UNDER THE LARGEST OF STARS OF
THE INPUT.
INTERNET MALL FOR A BILATERAL.
COOLEY INVESTMENT IN.
NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE THERE ARE.
NEARLY NO INVESTMENT.
FROM THE US THE FIRST THE
CAMPAIGN ENTER.
CHINA IS THE COCA COLA SO ONE
THEY NEGOTIATE TO THE THE TO
ESTABLISH A BUT TRADITIONS IN
THE SAME BUILDING.
BEIJING INTERNATIONAL PLOP
ANOTHER NEGOTIATION WHAT'S GOING
ON THAT SIR.
COCA COLA IS -- TO NEGOTIATION
THE BAYS -- TO ME ON CHINA FOOD.
WHAT'S AN EXPORT COMPANY
[INAUDIBLE]
SO.
YEAH BUT THE END OF THE LAST
YEAR THE US HAS THE
INVESTIGATING CHINA -- OVER.
US HI ANGIE. SEVEN HUNDRED SEVEN
LET ME SEE.
OVER THE SEVENTY THOUSAND TO
PROTECTING CHINA.
AND BIG COMPANIES LIKE A BOEING
MACROS.
INTO HER INTEL STOCK CUT THE
PILA.
GENERAL MOTORS NIKE.
GENERALLY LACKED TRICK.
THE I PO.
CISCO DOES A LOT OF THOSE
COMPANIES THESE THREE COMPANIES
BASE THEY IN BAY AREA.
AND OTHERS MAKE PROFITS AND
REVENUES AND PAY TAX CREATE JOB
OPPORTUNITIES TO BOTH COUNTRIES.
SO NO SINGLE COMPANY.
WAS UP FOR THE BY CHINESE
GOVERNMENT TO DOING LAST IN
CHINA.
AND NOT A SINGLE US COPS
CUSTOMER IS FORCED TO BUY CHINA
TO BUY.
A SINGLE CHINESE PRODUCTS THAT'S
ALL WELL AND TORY. TO DO
BUSINESS A GRAY BY BOTH SIDES.
TEN IS THE INVESTMENT TO THE U.
S. ALSO WITH UNEASE.
GREAT TO HIM [INAUDIBLE]
THE INCREASE.
BY THE END OF LAST YEAR.
THE DIRECTING THE MAN TO CHINA.
FROM CHINA TO THE U. S..
HE IS THE TWO SIXTY THREE POINT
THREE BILLION U. S. THE ORDER.
CREATING.
OVER ONE HUNDRED FORTY THOUSAND
JOBS FOR THE U. S. EACH YEAR.
SO IT'S REALLY A WIN BEING
CORPORATION NO MAKE COUNTRY
CORPORATION [INAUDIBLE]
IN.
TERMS TO OFFER.
I DO CATION UNDER TOURISM. EIGHT
TWENTY EIGHTEEN ABOUT THREE
MEDIAN CHINESE.
THE VISITED THE U. S. SPENDING
AS HOT AYE AYES SO IT'LL BE A U.
S. THE ORDER.
AT THE PRESIDENT TO ROUTE OUT
FOUR HUNDRED AND TWENTY THOUSAND
CHINESE TO STUDENT STUDYING IN
THE US COM.
BRING IT ON INCOME OF OVER
EIGHTEEN BEATING US DOLLAR EVERY
TOOL AMERICAN.
UNIVERSITIES.
ANYWAY [INAUDIBLE]
CALIFORNIA.
IS TAKING THE LEAD ON THE ENJOY
A VERY GUTEN.
BENEFICIAL COOPERATION WITH
CHINA.
I WAS STATE EIGHT AGING THE
EIGHTY ARE NUMBER FORTY FULL OF
CALIFORNIA STATE US SOMEBODY.
PASTA ÓNG.
OKAY THE THIRTEENTH LAST YEAR.
CHINA IS THE CUTTING YES THE
LARGEST TRADING PARTNER THE
LARGEST ASSAULT OF IMPORTS UNDER
THE SECOND THE LARGEST.
EXPLORE THE DEPTHS IN THE OCEAN
AS WELL AS CALIFORNIA'S
IMPORTANT PONOMAREV PARTNER IN
CLIMATE CHANGE.
ON THE GREEN DEVELOPMENT
CORPORATION.
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR.
REPRESENTED TING A CALIFORNIA --
THE POTTER -- IN BEIJING'S THE
SECOND COMING TO ALL FOR BELT
AND ROAD DO YOU MADE.
EXCELLENT A REMARKS TO TO
PROMOTE.
TO CLIMATE CHANGE CORPORATION
AROUND THE BELT AND ROAD AND
BETWEEN THE ALL A GREAT NATION.
WE APPRECIATE VERY MUCH.
AND WE ALSO WANT TO INVITE HUMAN
THE GOVERNOR AND THE OTHER PIECE
OF THESE PERCENT.
AT TWO WILL PARTICIPATE AS THE
HONG KONG INTERNATIONAL BELT AND
THE ROAD TO A SEMINAR -- AND
ALSO THE SHANGHAI AND
INTERNATIONAL IMPORT EXPORT BY
THE END OF THESE YEAR WOULD BE
THE ONE TO SEE MORE PRODUCTS A
NINE THE SERVICE.
FROM CALIFORNIA TO BE SHOWN IN
HONG KONG AND SHANGHAI
[INAUDIBLE]
UNDER THE IN.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN CALIFORNIA TREAT
WILLIAMS WITH CHINA REACHED. ONE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY SEVEN POINT
THE FIFTY THREE BEATING. THREE
IN TOTAL ACCOUNTING.
FOR NEARLY 27% OF THE US TOTAL
WITH CHINA.
ON THE CALIFORNIA ATTACK TASTES
CHINESE THE INVESTIMENTO. TWENTY
SIX POINT EIGHT BILLION USD.
RANKING FIRST AMONG ALL STATES
IN THE U. S..
CALIFORNIA. TO A ONE SIX MILLION.
CHINESE TOURISTS VISITING
CALIFORNIA.
MAKING CUTS EIGHT THE MOST THE A
CHECK DATE.
STATE FOR THE CHINESE TOURIST IN
U. S..
AND EVERY.
WEEK OVER TWENTY COMMERCIAL --
EVERY DATE NEARLY.
TWENTY COMMERCIAL.
FROM FLYING BETWEEN MAJOR CITIES.
IN CALIFORNIA AINA SAN FRANCISCO
I ALREADY.
SO JOSE OAKLAND SANTIAGO TO
BEIJING SHANHAIGUAN JOE'S BEYOND
JUNGLE TING DAHLE HONG KONG
TAIPEI EXCEPT.
FOR HISTORY AND TO HAS PROVEN
THAT CHINA THE US.
ALL HIDING TO DEPEND AND TING
ECONOMY ON THE CLOSELY INTO
WAITING.
INTEREST ON OUR COMMON INTEREST
FAR AWAY DIFFERENCES CORPORATION
IS THE ONLY RIGHT CHOICE.
UNFORTUNATELY AS MENTIONED BY ED
WITHIN THE GOVERNOR AND THE MY
FRIEND PHILIP TING THE TARIFFS
AND TRADE WILL INITIATE.
A DEAD BY.
THE FEDERAL ADMINISTRATION
ALREADY LOST TO THE FULL.
FIFTEEN MODEL CITIES.
AND SOME PEOPLE IN THE U. S..
NICK LAP TO THE NATURE.
OF MUTUALLY BENEFIT ON WHEN
BEING COOPERATION BETWEEN OUR
TWO COUNTRIES.
THEY PREACH IS OUR EQUIPMENT.
OF THE ARGUMENT OF LOSING MONEY
IN STATE OF HIS CHINA.
ON THE PRO PROVOKE TREE TO
FRICTION UNDER THE EXCUSE OF
TRADE DEFICIT.
AND INCREASING TARIFFS ON
CHINESE PRODUCTS.
OTHER FEW PEOPLE STICK TO THE
ZERO SUM SINKING AND PREACH.
THE T..
PLAYING OF CHINESE AND AMERICAN.
ECONOMIES UNITED TEND TO TO
LAUNCH THE SO CALLED NEW CODE
WALL.
OKAY TO THE REPORT -- TO FULL
FULL POST NEWS US EXPORTS TO
CHINA FAILED BY NEARLY 20%.
THE FIRST HALF OF THIS YEAR DUE
TO THE IMPACT OF TERRORISTS.
THE FIGURE IS NINETEEN POINT.
86%.
THE EXPORT OF SOY BEANS ALL YOU
NATURAL GAS CRAP CRAP HER COLTON
ON THE MOTOR VEHICLE WAS.
WELL ALL HURT BADLY [INAUDIBLE]
IN CALIFORNIA.
ACCORDING TO THE MEDIA REPORTS.
A SOFT TARIFFS.
HAS GREATLY IMPACTED THE LAW TO
TAKE INDUSTRY IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
REACH HI AFFECTED THE ONE MADE
IN TROUBLE.
RELATED. TO INTERNATIONAL TRADE.
ON THE IN THE IN THE REGION AND
THE FACT.
EIGHT NORMAL OPERATION OF SUPPLY
CHAIN.
CALIFORNIA PRODUCTS OF SUCH AS
THE MOANS.
LEMONS [INAUDIBLE]
THIRTY EIGHT CITRUS.
CRANBERRY AND CALIFORNIA.
ONE HAVE MADE A CONSIDERABLE
PROFIT IN EXPORT TO CHINA BUT
NOW CALIFORNIA GROWERS.
I HAVE SUFFERED A LOSS DUE TO
THEIR SHRINKING CHINA MARKET AS
MENTIONED BY LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR.
OTHER COUNTRIES.
TAKES OTHER WANTED TO ALL OF
THESE TARIFFS.
POSING TO CHINA.
CHAILEY.
ONE AUSTRIA.
ONE EXPORTER CHINA SEARCH WHEN
YOU LOSE THE MARKET SHARE IS
VERY HARD TO REGAIN.
SO THE DAHLE TWELVE EXAMPLE
PROVED.
THE PERSON TREAT A BATON CICERO
TREATABLE WE WILL BRING ALL
DISEASE RESULT.
YOUR COMPANIES THIS THAT AND THE
CUSTOMER.
HI TO PAY FOR IT.
LIKE THE U. S. UNDER THE REST OF
THE WORLD.
CHINA'S DEVELOPMENT GO IS TO
WORK HARD TO BRING A BETTER LIFE
TO THE CHINESE PEOPLE.
WE HAVE NO INTENTION TO
CHALLENGE AND REPLACED THE
POSITION OF THE US.
USA IS THE NUMBER ONE PICK
BROWSER.
NO I WAY.
INTERESTED IN.
SUPPORTING IDEOLOGY AND WHETHER
IT WAS YEAH.
ABLE PUTTING ASIDE EIGHT
DIFFERENT CITIES ON SINKING.
BROWN IS THE RIGHT WAY.
BY WORKING TOGETHER US AND CHINA
COME MAKE A LOT OF ACHIEVEMENT
THAT'S BETTER PROMOTE MUTUAL.
DEVELOPMENT.
WE DO WANT TO TREAT A WALL.
WE ARE NOTED OF RADIO FIT.
CHINA HAS ALWAYS BEEN OPEN TO
NEGOTIATION ALREADY AND I
HAVEN'T AND I'VE BEEN AROUND.
THIS MUST BE BASED ON MUTUAL
RESPECT MUTUAL.
EQUALITY.
HONESTY AND INTEGRITY AND CANNOT
BE CARRIED ALMOST UNDER THE
STARTUP TARIFFS NO AT THE
EXPENSE OF CHINA'S RIGHT --
DEVELOPMENT.
AS THE WORLD.
TOLD TOLD TOOL ECONOMIES.
IT IS NORMAL FOR TWO COUNTRIES
TO HIVE SOME DIFFERENCES.
THE KEY IS -- TO MANAGE AND
CONTROLS ARE BASED IN THE SPIRIT
OF TO RESPECT.
IT OKAY AND THE MUTUAL BENEFIT I
WONDER SALUTE SOLUTION.
ACCEPTABLE TO BOTH SIDES STILL
DIALOGUE ON THE CONSULTATION.
US CHINA RELATIONS IS THE THING
THEY HAVEN'T TRACED OFF CLOSE TO
EUROPE AND CHINA AND ALSO THE
RIGHT OF ALL OF THE THE REST OF
THE WORLD.
AS PRESIDENT XI JINPING FOUND
OUT.
A GOOD RELATIONSHIP.
BENEFITTED BOSS WHILE
CONFRONTATION.
DOES HOT TO POST COUNTRY.
CORPORATION IS BETTER DONE
FRICTION.
HELLO IS BETTER THAN
CONFRONTATION.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO BASED ON A
FEW.
POUNDS THIS IMPORTANT RELATIONS
SPECIALTY CHINA'S COOPERATION
REYES THE CALIFORNIA NUMBER FIVE
WARNING ECONOMY.
THANK YOU EVERYBODY THAT WORK
TOGETHER LAST BRING.
SIGNING TO THE SKY FOR BETTER
RELATIONS.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH -- DEPUTY
COUNSEL GENERAL WE'RE GONNA GO
MOVE INTO OUR PANELISTS AND
HOPEFULLY HAVE LITTLE DIALOGUE
AFTER EACH OF OUR PANELISTS
SPEAK.
SO FIRST WE HAVE DARLENE CHIU
BRIAN WHO'S THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF GLOBAL AS SELF.
THANK YOU SETTLEMENT TANK.
REALLY HONORED TO BE INVITED TO
SPEAK TODAY AND IT'S GOOD TO SEE
YOU AGAIN LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR --
THIS ONLY WOMEN JUST BECAUSE
LONG AND TONI GOOD TO SEE YOU
AGAIN -- FIRST OF ALL I'D LIKE
TO START WITH TELLING A STORY --
SOME PEOPLE KNOW CHINA STUFF.
THAT'S WHERE I CAME FROM AND
SOME PEOPLE DO NOT AND I LIKE TO
SAY THAT IN TWO THOUSAND AND
FIVE WHICH IS TRUE -- AS CHIEF
DEPUTY COMMUNICATIONS DIRECTOR
OF GAVIN NEWSOM WE WENT TO CHINA
ON HIS VERY FIRST MISSION TO
CHINA AND I REMEMBER AT THE TIME
FOR US TO LEAVE AND TING ALSO
JOINED US -- AS THE ASSESSOR
RECORDER OF SAN FRANCISCO.
THEN MAYOR GAVIN NEWSOM WAS SO --
IMPRESSED WITH WHAT HE THOUGHT
IN CHINA THAT HE CAN'T MAKE IT
IS THAT I'M STARTING A CHINA
DEATH WE HAVE TO DO SOMETHING
WITH CHINA SET ASIDE DOLLARS SET
ASIDE TWO POINT ONE MILLION.
AND I SAID I'LL BELIEVE IT WHEN
I SEE IT AND AND LO AND BEHOLD
IN TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHT HE DID
START CHINA AND STUFF.
I CAME ON BOARD IN -- TWENTY
TWELVE SINCE TWENTY TWELVE UNDER
CHINA'S SELF WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
BRING IN OVER FIVE DOLLARS FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS IN FOREIGN
DIRECT INVESTMENT.
WE HELP CREATE OVER. EIGHT
HUNDRED JOBS AND WE WE WE COULD
IT OVER A HUNDRED COMPANIES SAN
FRANCISCO AND ALSO GREATER BAY
AREA.
IN -- TWENTY FIFTEEN BECAUSE OF
THE SUCCESS OF CHINA'S STUFF IN
MAYOR ED LEE DECIDED YOU KNOW
WHAT WE HAVE TO LOOK AT OTHER
REGIONS ADDED.
AS OF ASIA TO LOOK AT AGE
OUTSIDE OF CHINA AS WELL AS
LATIN AND STUFF.
AND LIGHTNESS OF LOOK AT LATIN
AMERICA FOR OF HIS REASONS
BECAUSE THEY'RE IN A BACKYARD --
AND NOW AS GLOBAL SF.
WE ARE A PARTNER THE CITY AND
COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO AND WE
CONTINUE TO LOOK AT WHAT
OPPORTUNITIES THERE ARE OUT
THERE.
SOME OF THE ACTIVITIES THAT
WE'VE ASKED HELD -- SINCE --
I'VE BEEN IN THIS POSITION AND
SOME OF THE AREAS THAT WE'VE
BEEN FOCUSED ON WE'VE WORKED ON
ENERGY EFFICIENCY WE PARTNER OF
MANY TIMES WITH THE MINISTRY OF
COMMERCE IN CHINA -- WE HOSTED
AND PARTNERED WITH FLAT USA --
WHETHER ATTENDING THE SLIGHT USA
SUMMIT IN DC OR ALSO HOSTING THE
SPIN OFFS WHERE WE BRING
DELEGATES FROM NOT JUST KINDA
BUT AROUND THE WORLD TO SAN
FRANCISCO AND THE BAY AREA TO
LOOK AT OPPORTUNITIES HERE.
OF WE'VE ACTUALLY HOSTED THE
FIRST FINTECH CONFERENCE IN SAN
FRANCISCO AND TWENTY SIXTEEN AND
ON THE CULTURAL SIDE WHETHER
WE'RE WORKING WITH THE
BUSINESSES OR EVEN CITIES.
TO YOU KNOW OUT TO AS THEY SAY
CULTURE FOLLOWS BUSINESS BECAUSE
YOU HAVE MONEY YOU CAN ACTUALLY
INVESTING CULTURE AS I SAY.
WE'VE WORKED WITH MULTI OF MANY
PEOPLE DO NOT KNOW NOT WHAT
MULTI IS.
DOING BUSINESS IN CHINA IF YOU
DO NOT KNOW MULTI YOU ARE NOT A
CHINA HAND -- BUT WE'VE -- THAT
WE HAVE WORKED WITH THEM TO
EXPAND THE TICKET HERE IN THE US
AND THE US THE MULTI DAY --
WHICH IS A CELEBRATION SINCE.
TWENTY FIFTEEN OF WE'VE WORKED
WITH CHUNG DO THIS IF TELL DO SO
THAT PEOPLE KNOW THAT SINCE ONE
IS NOT THIS ONE FOOD BUT THERE'S
ACTUALLY JOHN CHIANG AND TALKING
TO RIGHT.
THE WHOLE OF THE PANDA -- AND
WE'VE ACTUALLY WHAT WOULD BY DUE
TO BECAUSE TECHNOLOGY IS IS.
AS WE ALL KNOW -- PART OF OUR
SOUL IN SAN FRANCISCO AND
SILICON VALLEY AND CHINA IS
GREATLY IS CATCHING UP IN SOME
SOME MAY SAY EVEN SURPASSING US.
BUT BY DO HAS BEEN ONE OF THEIR
STRONG.
ANCHORS IN CHINA AND WE HAVE
WORKED WITH THEM TO SEE HOW WE
CAN EXPLORE PARTNERSHIPS IN THE
US.
FROM THE ALBUM PERSPECTIVE WHAT
PEOPLE SAY HEY DON'T YOU TWO
DELEGATIONS AND WE SAY YES WE'VE
DONE THAT.
DID YOU FISH AND SEE WE WE ARE
ACTUALLY -- TOOK THE
COMMISSIONER OF OF OF ENERGY
RIGHT -- I FORGET THE NAME OF
SORRY BUT WE WENT IN TWENTY
THIRTEEN AND THEN -- WE IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN WE ACTUALLY START
THAT IN TAKING DELEGATES FROM
PARIS IS GOING TO BE AREA TO
CHINA TO LOOK AT EXPLORE.
PARTNERSHIPS -- WORK AND
BRINGING INVESTMENT TO US HOW
WOMEN TWENTY THIRTEEN I SHOULD
PASS WE DID TO THE FIRST
INVESTING U. S. REAL ESTATE
SUMMIT -- WITH THEN AMBASSADOR
GARY LAW IN BEIJING IS PROBABLY
ONE OF THE FIRST ONES AT THE
TIME THAT WAS EVER DONE AND I
TELL YOU WHEN I ARRIVED IN
BEIJING WE HAD THE SUMMIT.
I REMEMBER IT WAS ON MONDAY I
CAME BACK ON TUESDAY ON
WEDNESDAY ALREADY HAD A CLIENT
FLYING IN TO SERVICES GOING
THING I'M READY TO LOOK AT ALL
THE PROJECT YOU TALKED ABOUT.
AND THAT CLIENT NOW HAS IN THE
ABOUT THREE BILLION DOLLARS IN
CALIFORNIA ALONE HE IS NOT GOING
TO ANY OTHER STATE.
WHICH IS GREAT FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND HE CONTINUES --
TO INVEST IN THIS GREAT STATE --
WE HAVE ACTUALLY DIVERSIFIED A
LITTLE BIT KNOWING THAT -- REAL
ESTATE EVEN THOUGH WE SAY THE
CHINESE INVESTED AND BROUGHT UP
AND RAISED ON THE PRICES THAT'S
ACTUALLY NOT TRUE IF YOU LOOK AT
ACTUALLY THE WHO ARE PURCHASING
PROPERTY.
THE CONSUMER IS LEFT TENTH 12%
OF THOSE CONSUMERS AREN'T
TRAINEES OR FOREIGN NATIONALS
ACTUALLY IS THE LOCALS IF I
TECHIES WHO ARE MAKING MONEY AND
HELPING OUR ECONOMY SO I LIKE TO
ALWAYS.
I'LL MAKE A NOTE OF THAT AND LET
PEOPLE KNOW.
AND THEN RECENTLY THIS YEAR
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT MONEY IS
CALLED TO LEAVE CHINA -- WE
ACTUALLY BROUGHT A DELEGATION OF
START UPS FROM SAN FRANCISCO BAY
AREA EVEN WENT AS FAR AS COMING
FROM NEW YORK.
AND WE BOUGHT THIRTEEN START TO
CHINA THIS YEAR EARLIER THIS
YEAR -- BECAUSE WE WANT IT CHINA
TO SEE WHAT START UPS ARE LIGHT
IN THE FROM THE SAN FRANCISCO
BAY AREA -- AND WE WON AT THE
LOCAL STARBUCKS TO SEE WHETHER
OR NOT THERE ARE OPPORTUNITIES
FROM THEM IN CHINA.
WHETHER IT BE OPENING A MARKET
WHETHER IT BE MANUFACTURING SOME
OF THE ITEMS THAT ARE PART OF
THEIR PRODUCT LINE -- OR WHETHER
IT BE FINDING PARTNERS AND
INVESTORS IN CHINA OR BRINGING
THEM INTO THE US.
WHAT ARE WE FOCUSED ON -- AND
WHY IS IT NECESSARY FOR WHAT WE
FOCUSED ON I SHOULD SAY --
MOVING FORWARD AND WHY IS IT
NECESSARY TO AYE EVEN HALF
CHINESE INVESTMENT BECAUSE CHINA
HAS BEEN A PARTNER AND ALREADY
WE'VE HEARD THAT -- YOU KNOW
THERE IS A TRADE DEFICIT AND
THERE'S A HUGE IMPACT.
CHINESE DOLLARS HAVE BEEN HAVE
BEEN IMPORTANT IN KICK STARTING.
OUR ECONOMY MANY WAYS AND SOME
PEOPLE DO NOT UNDERSTAND.
FUNKY CAME ON BOARD AND THEY
ACTUALLY STARTED BUILDING THE
CONDOS AND SOUTH OF MARKET -- I
REMEMBER WHEN A PICK AT NO ALSO
KNOWN AS THING HIGH E. THEY
BOUGHT STRESS PROPERTIES AND
SOUTH OF MARKET -- AND MEN AND
FIVE HOTELS GAVE PEOPLE JOBS.
AND THEY'VE BEEN ABLE TO HELP
THE ECONOMY -- AND OTHER
COMPANIES.
SUCH AS OCEAN WIDE AND THEY WERE
ABLE TO START AND BUILD AND
BREAK GROUND ON TWO MILLION
SQUARE FEET.
IN OUR TRANSMIT TERMINAL.
BEFORE THAT TIME THERE WAS
REALLY NO MOVEMENT IN THE
TRANSKEI AREA.
AND GREY EAGLE DOING BUSINESS AS
SPECIFIC EAGLE IN SAN FRANCISCO
THEY'VE BEEN HERE FOR TWENTY
YEARS AND ALL THEY DID WAS HOLD
ON TO THEIR STABILIZE ASSETS BUT
REALIZE THAT YOU KNOW IT IS TIME
FOR US TO MOVE FORWARD.
AND THEY DID BY LAND GREENFIELD
AND THEY ARE DEVELOPING.
AND THEY ACTUALLY STE ARE ALMOST
AND AND THEY ARE DEVELOPING
ACTUALLY THREE PROJECT ONE IS
ALREADY COMPLETED IN SAN
FRANCISCO.
AND EVEN THOUGH THE VIDEO
SACRAMENTO I WANTED TO ADD
BECAUSE MY FRIEND MADE SURE I
SAID SOMETHING.
IN SACRAMENTO THE KING'S STADIUM
HAS -- ACTUALLY PARTNERED WITH
FOREIGN INVESTORS.
OUT AND BROUGHT IN TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS TO DEVELOP
SACRAMENTO DOWNTOWN AND THAT IS
VERY IMPORTANT I THINK FOR
ECONOMY NOT JUST RESONANCES GO.
BACK CALIFORNIA.
LOOKING FORWARD WHAT ARE WE
LOOKING AT NOW WITH THIS --
CHECK A TERRACE WAR.
WE'RE LOOKING AT FOOD WE'RE
LOOKING AT FOOD TECH WE'RE
LOOKING UP WHILE WE'RE LOOKING
AT FOOD SECURITY.
AND OTHER MARKETS WELL BECAUSE
WE KNOW THAT YOU KNOW AS GLOBAL
AS SOUTH AND EVEN THOUGH WE
STILL HAVE CHINA CHINA WE WILL
CONTINUE TO DO BUSINESS -- AND
AND MOVE FORWARD.
THIS YEAR WE AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER WE ALREADY TOOK A
DELEGATION AND KINDA LOOKING AT
BRINGING -- START UPS TO CHINA
HOWEVER WE ARE IT WITH FOOD TECH
TAKING A DELEGATION TO SINGAPORE
AND HONG KONG TO TALK ABOUT FOOD
TECH AND BRING FOOD TECHNOLOGY
TO ASIA.
AND LOOK THE CHINA MARKET.
AND IN NOVEMBER WE ALSO TAKING A
DELEGATION TO SHANGHAI TO
PARTICIPATE AT THE IMPORT EXPO
SO AND WE'RE BRINGING FOOD
COMPANIES AS WELL SO WE ARE
LOOKING EVEN THOUGH THERE'S A
TEAR FOR WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE CHINA MARKET IS
INFORMED.
AND EDUCATED ABOUT WHAT IS GOING
ON ESPECIALLY IN THE FOOD IN IN
FOOD WORLD AND IN SECURITY
BECAUSE THAT IS ESSENTIAL TO THE
GROWTH IN CHINA AND ALSO TO THE
US.
OTHER MARKETS OUTSIDE OF CHINA I
ONLY SAY WHAT ARE WE GOING TO
DIVERSIFY WHAT WE'RE DOING WE'RE
ACTUALLY LOOKING AT ASIA OF
COURSE.
RIGHT WHETHER BE NORTH AND SOUTH
EAST ASIA INDIA IS AN IMPORTANT
MARKET FOR US -- LATIN AMERICA
AUSTRALIA THE MIDDLE EAST EUROPE
AND EASTERN EUROPE AND I SHOULD
KNOW THAT OF COURSE WITH THE ONE
BUILT ONE ROAD INITIATIVE THAT
WE ARE LOOKING TO SEE WHERE
CHINA'S GOING.
AND ALSO PARTNERED WITH THEM AS
WELL FOR EXAMPLE LATIN AMERICA
WE ARE TAKING A DELEGATION OF
FROM SAN FRANCISCO TO LATIN
AMERICA IN SEPTEMBER.
BECAUSE AND THE THING IS WE ALSO
KNOW THAT CHINA HAS BEEN SENDING
A LOT OF COMPANIES TO INVEST IN
SOUTH AMERICA AS WELL.
SO WE ARE WE ARE AND AND SO WE
KNOW THAT THERE'S A TREND THERE
BUT WE DEFINITELY WORKING.
AND WITH THAT I THINK I FINISH
MY COMMENTS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU.
STEPHEN CHUNK WHO'S THE
PRESIDENT OF THE WORLD TRADE
CENTER LOS ANGELES [INAUDIBLE]
CHAU.
THANK YOU SOME TEN FROM BITING
ME -- TO SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
THE LOS ANGELES REGION AND THANK
YOU FOR THE GOVERNOR FOR
SUPPORTING US SO MUCH WITHOUT
LOS ANGELES IN MULTIPLE EVENTS
AND THE COULD JESSICA FOR THE
INVITATION -- AS WE TALK ABOUT
CALIFORNIA I THINK SOMETIMES WE
THINK OF LOS -- CALIFORNIA'S A
WHOLE BLOCK AND I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR US TO SEPARATE A
LITTLE BIT AND THAT'S MY IN
FRONT OF YOU -- YOU SEE A A
COUPLE SLIDE JUST TO REMIND.
US OF THE VARIOUS INDUSTRIES ARE
GROWING THROUGHOUT THE
CALIFORNIA REGION AND HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS TO TO THE WORLD
THAT WE SEE THE VARIOUS
OPPORTUNITIES ARE AVAILABLE SO
FAR SOMEONE A HIGHLIGHT A COUPLE
FACTS ABOUT LOS ANGELES AND TALK
ABOUT THE IMPACT OF CHINA.
AND WHAT IT MEANS TO US AS WE'RE
MOVING FORWARD WITH THE THE
CHURCH -- THE TARIFFS AND A
TRADE WAR.
SO FIRST -- LE PEN JUST COUNTY A
LOT OF PEOPLE DON'T KNOW ABOUT
OUR GDP LAST YEAR REACH A
STAGGERING EIGHT HUNDRED AND
SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS.
IF ONE SANDERS COUNTY ALONE WERE
COUNTRY WE WOULD BE THE
NINETEENTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN
THE WORLD.
I THINK PEOPLE LOOK AT
CALIFORNIA'S THE FIFTH LARGEST
ECONOMY IN THE WORLD BUT THEY
DON'T REALIZE THAT WE HAVE MANY
NATIONS WITHIN CALIFORNIA WITH
THE SIZES -- MANY NATIONS AS
WELL AND IN SEVEN CALIFORNIA ALL
TOGETHER TO TWENTY TWO MILLION
PEOPLE THAT LIVE THERE RG PIECE
ABOUT ONE POINT FIVE TRILLION
DOLLARS.
EQUATING TO HAVE A LOT OF
LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE WORLD
THAT'S THE SIZE OF OUR ECONOMY
DOWN IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND
THE REASON WHY WE DO SO WELL
WITH OUR OUR G. P..
AND THERE WAS INDUSTRY SECTORS
ARE GROWING SO STRONGLY IS
BECAUSE OF OUR NATIONAL TIES
WITH THE REST OF THE WORLD
SPECIFICALLY WHAT THE ASIA
PACIFIC.
THERE ARE OVER A MILLION JOBS
ARE DIRECTLY RELATED TO THE PART
OF LOS AS AS PART OF LONG BEACH
HAS SUPPORTED -- BY THE
ACTIVITIES ARE GOING ON AT THE
PORTS AS LEVEL WITHIN THE
GOVERNOR AND THE SENATE MEMBERS
MENTIONED EARLIER THE PLAY LOS
ANGELES IS THE NUMBER ONE
CONTAINER PORTS IN NORTH AMERICA
THE PORT OF LONG BEACH IS A
SECOND CONTENT -- LÀ LARGEST
CONTAINER PORTS IN NORTH AMERICA
COMBINED TOGETHER THE NINTH
LARGEST.
COMPLEX IN THE WORLD.
THESE TWO PORTS A LOCAL CONTROL
OVER 40% OF OCEAN GOING CARGO
COMING INTO THE UNITED STATES.
LOS ANGELES ALONE CONTROLS 43%.
OF THE GOODS COMING IN.
THE AND WE CONSUME A PARTIALLY.
A SOME OF THE GOODS BUT THE REST
OF MY ACTUALLY GOES TO THE REST
OF THE UNITED STATES SO THE
IMPACT IS NOT JUST LOCAL IS
ACTUALLY THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE
NATION.
AND BESIDES -- WHEN IT COMES
INTERNATIONAL TRADE BESIDES
IMPORT EXPORT REALLY HAVE TO
LOOK AT FOR DIRECT INVESTMENT AS
WELL?
AND WE ARE AT THE WAITRESS IN A
LOS ANGELES AND A LITTLE SAID
JUST COUNTY ECONOMIC I'M
CORPORATION WE DO AN ANNUAL
ANALYSIS OF THE NUMBER OF
FOREIGN ON THE SELFISHNESS
LOCATE IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
AND WE'RE VERY HAPPY TO REPORTS
THAT -- LAST YEAR OVER TEN
THOUSAND FOR KNOWN FORMS AND
SEVEN CALIFORNIA CONTRIBUTING
DIRECTLY TO OVER FOUR HUNDRED
AND TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND JOBS.
IN EVERY YEAR THESE PHONE ON THE
SABBATH SHIPMENTS.
LOCAL WAGES OF OVER THIRTY
BILLION DOLLARS THAT'S THE
IMPACT THAT FOREIGN INVESTMENTS
HAVE ON OUR REGION.
ON TOP OF THAT THE TRADING
LOGISTICS SECTOR WE SUPPORT
DIRECTLY ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED
EIGHTY THOUSAND JOBS IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA SO WE'RE REALLY
TALKING ABOUT OVER A MILLION
JOBS ARE DIRECTLY SUPPORTED BY
INTERNATIONAL TRADE.
AND AS REMOVING FOR THIS -- WHAT
WITH THE REPORT ITSELF FOCUS ON
MANUFACTURING?
AND MANY FOLKS AROUND THE WORLD
INCLUDING THE UNITED STATES
FORGET THAT CALIFORNIA AND LOS
ANGELES A PARTICULAR -- I HAVE
VERY STRONG MANUFACTURING
CAPABILITIES IN FACT LOS ANGELES
COUNTY IS THE NUMBER ONE COUNTY
IN THE ENTIRE UNITED STATES WITH
OVER THREE HUNDRED SIXTY
THOUSAND MANUFACTURING JOBS LOOK
AT WRITING LÀ.
I COUNTY ALONE COMBINED WITH THE
REST OF CALIFORNIA THIS IS A
HUGE IMPACT AND WE MANUFACTURE
WE DON'T JUST PRODUCE EVERYTHING
FROM SCRATCH WE HAVE TO IMPORT A
LOT OF THE COMPONENT PARTS.
ESPECIALLY FOR MY PARTNERS IN
ASIA AND THE STREET PTEROPUS
ACTUALLY HAVING A HUGE IMPACT
WHICH I'LL TALK ABOUT A BIT
LATER.
AS WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD IN
TERMS OF THESE FOREIGN COMPANIES
ARE COMING AND WE'RE ALSO SEEING
THAT THEY'RE CREATING NEW
OPPORTUNITIES THAT WE'VE NEVER
SEEN BEFORE AND ALSO SATAN JOBS
OUT MY HAVE LEFT US -- IN TWO
THOUSAND AND FOURTEEN THERE'S A
COMPANY -- NESTLE -- THEY OWN --
A PRODUCT THAT HE GETS BY A VERY
TO BILLY WHAT'S HOT POCKETS.
BECAUSE YOU SEE BE MANUFACTURED
RIGHT IN LOS ANGELES IN
CHATSWORTH TWO HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY JOBS ARE SO SUPPORT THIS
OPERATION THEY DECIDE TO MOVE
THE MANUFACTURING PLANT TO
KENTUCKY.
AND SO WE WERE REALLY STRESS IN
TERMS OF WHAT WE'RE GOING TO
HAPPEN TO THESE MANUFACTURING
JOBS AND THESE INDIVIDUALS ARE
LIVING IN CHATSWORTH.
AND THAT'S WHEN WE WERE ABLE TO
RECRUIT A CHINESE COMPANIES AND
THERE.
CAME IN AND BASICALLY WERE ABLE
TO TRANSFORM THE MANUFACTURING
PLANTS TO MAKE CHINESE DUMPLINGS.
THAT ARE NOW SOLD IN NINETY NINE
RANCH MARKET AND IN A FROZEN
DUMPLINGS ACROSS THE UNITED
STATES WHAT A GREAT WAY TO SAVE
THE JOBS AND REALLY CATER TO THE
NEEDS OF THE LOCAL POPULATION.
ANOTHER COMPANY SB RIGHTY --
FROM CHANGE AND OUR CHECK BOB
THAT'S MANUFACTURE THAT'S COME
TO LOS ANGELES AND OPEN NOT ONLY
THE NORTH AMERICAN HEADQUARTERS
BUT THEIR MANUFACTURING CENTER
LANCASTER WITHIN PLAN THAT RATE
WAS HIGHER THAN THE REST OF THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
AND THROUGH THAT AND THROUGH
YEARS OF REALLY DEVELOPMENT
THEY'RE ABLE TO CREE OVER EIGHT
HUNDRED MANUFACTURING JOBS.
GOOD PAYING MANUFACTURING JOBS
IN THAT LOCATION THAT WAS REALLY
DESPERATE FOR FOR NEW
OPPORTUNITIES.
AND BECAUSE BE READY IS MAKING
ELECTRIC BUSES AND THEY'RE
GETTING CONTRACTS FROM LA COUNTY
METRO WERE ABLE TO SEE IS OUT
THERE AFTER A TRACKING OTHER
COMPANIES.
THERE'S A COMPANY CALLED TRITIUM
FROM AUSTRALIA A SMALL ELECTRIC --
FESTERING STATION COMPANY I CAME
TO LOS ANGELES SPECIFICALLY TO
PROVIDE THAT SERVICE -- FOR B.
Y. DE UNFORTUNATELY DO NOT ABLE
TO PROVIDE THAT DOCTOR
CONNECTION HOWEVER THEY WERE
ABLE TO PARTNER WITH THE TERROR
AND OTHER ELECTRIC BUS
MANUFACTURER NOW THIS COMPANY
WHAT FROM TO EMPLOYEES TO TWENTY
FOUR EMPLOYEES.
SO THESE ARE JOB CREATION THE
MULTIPLIER EFFECT ARE HAPPENING
BECAUSE OF INTERNATIONAL
INVESTMENT THAT'S COMING IN.
THE FOCUS WILL BE ON THE CHINESE
INVESTMENT AS WELL -- A LOT OF
PEOPLE WHEN THEY THINK OF LOS
ANGELES THEY THINK CHINA IS
USUALLY ARE NUMBER ONE TRADING
ARE AT FOREIGN INVESTOR -- THEY
ARE WHEN IT COMES TO THE THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT'S BEEN
COMING IN OVER THE YEARS HOWEVER
WHEN WE COUNT THE NUMBER OF JOBS
AND THE NUMBER OF COMPANIES ARE
HERE CHINA'S JUST GROWING INTO
INTO THE NUMBER EIGHT POSITION.
OUR TOP INVESTORS SO JAPAN U. K.
CANADA GERMANY.
FRANCE SO CHINA'S MAKING LEAPS
AND BOUNDS MOVING FORWARD AND
OVER THE PAST FEW YEARS IF YOU
LOOK AT REPORT BY THE RHODIUM
GROUP YOU SEE THAT WE HAVE BEEN
HAVING A LOT OF NEW GREEN FIELD
AND THAT'S COMING IN.
IN TWO THOUSAND AND NINETEEN FOR
EXAMPLE THERE ARE OVER FIFTY
THREE DEALS ACROSS CALIFORNIA
CONTRIBUTING ABOUT FOUR POINT
SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN SIXTY SEVEN
PROJECTS SIXTEEN POINT FOUR
BILLION. TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
SIXTY SIX PROJECT ONE BILLION
UNFORTUNATELY LOST WE SAW A
SHARP DECLINE.
DURING BATTLE DEALS IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN WITH TWO
HUNDRED AND NINETY NINE MILLION
DOLLARS THAT'S A HUGE DROP.
AND I SAID ONLY MENTION -- SOME
THE PROJECTS ARE HAVING SAN
FRANCISCO ALSO TRANSFORMING LOS
ANGELES AS WELL -- OCEAN WHY
GREENLAND ALL OF THESE COMPANIES
ALSO INVESTING HEAVILY INTO LOS
ANGELES CREATING NEW HOTELS IN
NEW RESIDENTIAL PROJECTS AROUND
DOWNTOWN LOS ANGELES AND GIVING
US A REAL RENAISSANCE THAT WE
HAVEN'T SEEN IN YEARS.
AS LOS ANGELES IS GETTING READY
FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT
OLYMPIC GAMES WILL BE HOSTING
FOR THE THIRD TIME WE DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH HOTEL ROOMS TO SUPPORT --
TO TO TO REALLY SUPPORT THIS
ENTIRE INFLUX OF TOYS AND COMING
IN AND BESIDES EVERYBODY'S
TALKING AT TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT
BUT WHAT I WANT TO TALK ABOUT.
202-223-2420 TWENTY NINE BECAUSE
WILL ALSO BE HOSTING -- OTHER
MAJOR EVENTS LIKE -- THE NC
DOUBLE A CHAMPIONSHIP THE US
OPEN -- SO WE'RE GOING TO BE THE
SPORTS ENTERTAINMENT CAPITAL OF
THE UNITED STATES FOR THE NEXT
TWENTY YEARS WE NEED THE HOTEL
ARE PROJECTS.
ANNOUNCING THIS DECLINE IS
REALLY AFFECTING US IN A
NEGATIVE MANNER AND WE'RE REALLY
CONCERNED.
NOW BACK TO THIS AS A FOREIGN
INVESTMENTS WE WHAT WE WERE
TALKING A BIT MORE ABOUT IMPORT
EXPORT AS LOW TECH GOVERNOR AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TALKED ABOUT AS
WELL.
THE MESSAGES BECAUSE SINCE THE
STRIKE LAST YEAR -- WE ARE AGAIN
THE NUMBER ONE CAUSE OF STRICKEN
UNITED STATES WENT OVER FOUR
HUNDRED THIRTY BILLION DOLLARS
IN TWO WAY TRADE WITH THE REST
OF THE WORLD OUR NUMBER ONE
TRADING PARTNER CHINA.
WITH OVER A HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
BILLION DOLLARS INTO A TRADE
WITH JUST WITH CHINA ALONE AND
THIS IS WHAT ARE THE VARIOUS
PORTS OF ENTRY AROUND THE THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA REGION.
WHAT'S TWO NOTES WHAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO KNOW IS THAT IF YOU
ADD UP THE SECOND LARGEST
TRADING PARTNER JAPAN -- NUMBER
THREE WHICH IS KOREA.
NUMBER FOUR NUMBER FIVE NUMBER
SIX NUMBER SEVENTY ADDED FROM
NUMBER TWO TO NUMBER TWELVE THEN
THAT NUMBER EQUALLED IT'S WHAT
WE TRADE WITH CHINA THAT'S THE
IMPACT OF TRADE THAT WE HAVE
WITH CHINA.
SO THE SPEECH THERAPIST REALLY
CONCERNING TO US BECAUSE WE'RE
SEEING A DROP AS THE THE WITH
THE GOVERNOR AND THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MENTIONED BEFORE THE PART
OF LOS ANGELES AND PART OF LONG
BEACH.
ALREADY REPORTED AND THE FOR SIX
MONTHS A SIX POINT 7% -- THE
DECREASE AND VOLUMES COMING INTO
LOS ANGELES THIS IS IMPACTING
NOT TO SUPPORT OPERATION BUT
WAREHOUSE A DISTRIBUTION CENTER
RAIL ASPECT AND ALSO OR
WHOLESALERS SO A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT.
COMPANIES ARE GOING TO BE IN AND
PACKED AT NEW PLAY BY IT BY THIS
CHANGE.
AND I ALSO WANT TO MENTION THAT
SITES WHEN WE THINK OF IMPORT
EXPORT WE ALWAYS FORGET THAT
THEIR AIR CARGO COMING IN.
LA X. S. THE NATION'S NUMBER TWO
AIRPORTS -- THE SECOND BUSIEST
AIRPORTS WITH THE EIGHTY SEVEN
POINT FIVE MILLION PASSENGERS
COMING IN EVERY YEAR AND THEY
WERE ALSO THE WORLD'S FOURTH
BUSIEST AIRPORTS WE PROCESS OVER
A HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS WORTH
OF GOODS THROUGH LAX ALONE EVERY
SINGLE YEAR.
AND WITH THAT WE ALSO HAVE ALL
THESE DIRECT FLIGHTS ARE
LAUNCHING -- AS THE THE BECAUSE
THE GENERAL MENTIONED BEFORE --
DRUG NONSTOP FLIGHTS -- TO WHAT
THIS TIME SHOCK WHETHER IT'S
SHALL DO -- LA LEADS THAT
BECAUSE WHEN WE DO THAT WERE
ABLE TO INCREASE OUR ECONOMIC
ACTIVITIES IT'S ESTIMATED THAT
EACH DAILY NON STOP DIRECT
FLIGHT COMING IN AND OUT OF LA
ACTS.
CREATES ABOUT A BILLION DOLLARS
OF ECONOMIC IMPACT TO THE LOCAL.
COMMUNITY EVERY SINGLE YEAR
THAT'S WHY WE WANT TO INCREASE
THESE NUMBERS AND WHAT'S BEEN
FASCINATING IS THAT'S GAIN.
AS WE'RE LOOKING AT THE NUMBERS
WE SAW ABOUT CHINESE TAURUS
ABOUT TWO YEARS AGO A LOS
ANGELES WITH THE FIRST CITY TO
HAVE OVER ONE MILLION PASS AND
VISITORS FROM CHINA -- TO LOS
ANGELES AND IT'S BEEN GROWING SO
LAST YEAR WE HAD A NEW NUMBER
WITH ONE POINT TWO MIL IN
CHINESE VISITORS.
HELLO -- ACTUALLY JUST HIT A NEW
RECORD THIS YEAR -- FIFTY
MILLION VISITORS CAME TO LOS
ANGELES AND WE LOVE OUR
INTERNATIONAL VISITORS BECAUSE
SPENT ABOUT TWENTY THREE POINT
NINE BILLION DOLLARS LOCALLY.
AND WITH THAT THEY ALSO CREE
ABOUT TWO POINT SIX BILLION
DOLLARS OF TAX REVENUE FOR THE
LOCAL AND A COMMUNITY AS WELL.
COMBINED TOGETHER YOU CAN SEE
THE IMPACT OF INTERNATIONAL
TRADE COMMUNITY AND HOW THAT
BRINGS EVERYBODY TOGETHER.
AND WE ARE NOW WITNESSING SOME
MAJOR -- ISSUES THAT ARE BEING
FACED BY OUR LOCAL SMALL AND
MEDIUM SIZE COMPANIES.
WITHIN GOVERNMENT XIN SOMEBODY
SINCE ALL COMPANIES DON'T HAVE
THE RESOURCES FOR SEEING THAT
ALLOWED THE MARKET.
THE COMPONENT PARTS FROM CHINA
THEY WERE LOOKING ANOTHER
LOCATION FOR MANUFACTURING US
ALTERNATIVE SOME OF THEM ARE
LOOKING TO MEXICO TO NEAR SHORE
UNFORTUNATELY A COUPLE WEEKS AGO
WHEN THE PRESIDENT DECIDED TO
ANNOUNCE THAT HE MIGHT BE ADDING
A 5%.
TAX A TARIFF ON MEXICO PRODUCT
COMING IN IT BASICALLY ALSO
CREDIT RISK FOR OUR COMPANIES TO
MOVE FROM CHINA TO MEXICO NOW
THEIR STOCK SO THERE'S A LOT OF
UNCERTAINTY THAT'S REALLY
CREATING SOME -- BACKLASH
BECAUSE THESE COMPANIES ARE NOW
HOLDING STILL AND THEY'RE NOT
MOVING FORWARD WITH THEIR
MANUFACTURING OR THEIR ORDERS
WHICH IS GONNA LATER ON DOWN THE
LINE IMPACT OUR TRADE LOGISTICS
WAREHOUSE ON THE NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT SECTORS -- LOOKING
FORWARD TO HAVING THAT MORE THE
ROBUST CONVERSATION BUT I WANTED
TO PROVIDE THE PERSPECTIVE WHEN
IT COMES TO LOS ANGELES AND
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
IN TERMS OF THE THINGS THAT
WE'VE BEEN SEEING THANK YOU FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY.
THANK YOU JOHN.
WE'RE HONORED TO HAVE MISTER
JUST IN SCREENS A SENIOR
RESEARCH FELLOW AT STANFORD
UNIVERSITY.
AS WELL SENIOR ADVISER AND THE
CLARITY.
MCCARTY ASSOCIATES.
MANAGER TING DISTINGUISHED
GUESTS LADIES DIAMOND THANKS
INVITATION I AM A NEW RESIDENTS
OF THE GOLDEN STATE LESS THAN A
YEAR I'VE BEEN ON THE GROUND
HERE.
IT'S REALLY AN AUTOMATIC PART OF
HIS HEARING.
OUR DEMOCRATIC SYSTEM THRIVES ON
DISCUSSION DEBATE TRANSPARENCY
AND OPENNESS AND HAVING HEARING
LIKE THIS.
IMPORTANT TOPIC OF TRADE
RELATIONS WITH CHINA SHOULD HELP
US MOVE TOWARDS THE BEST POLICY
SOLUTIONS IN THE WEEKS.
MONTHS AND YEARS AHEAD.
OVER THE LAST TWO DECADES I'VE
BEEN FORTUNATE TO WORK IN AND
OUT OF THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
IN WASHINGTON DC AND IN CHINA.
ON POLICY WITH ASIA MOST
RECENTLY.
TWENTY THIRTEEN TO TWENTY
EIGHTEEN I SERVED AT THE UNITED
STATES EMBASSY IN BEIJING AS THE
MINISTER CONCERT FOR TRADE.
I HOPE MY EXPERIENCE WORKING ON
LINE UP AND ON COMMERCIAL UP
SCHOOL CAN SHED SOME LIGHT ON
THE ISSUES AT HAND.
COMMITTEES CONSIDER THE BEST WAY
FORWARD. FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA FOR ITS CITIZENS IS
COMPANIES AND ITS FARMERS.
THE VIEWS I EXPRESSED TODAY ON
MY OWN AND DON'T REPRESENT THE
POLICIES OF UNITED STATES
GOVERNMENT.
UNITED TRADE REPRESENTATIVE OR
ANY OTHER ORGANIZATION OR
INSTITUTION AND JUST ONE PERSON
ONE VOTE WHEN WE MOVED AHEAD
WITH THE SECTION THREE OH WHAT.
DECISION THE PERSON THAT GOT THE
HONOR OF GOING TO THE MINISTRY
OF COMMERCE TO TELL THEM THAT WE
WERE DOING THAT WITH ME -- I WAS
WHAT YOU THREE AREAS THIS
MORNING -- FIRST HOW WE ARRIVED
AT THE STATE OF US CHINA TRADE
TENSIONS.
SECOND WEDDING CENTER THE MOMENT
AND WHAT'S LIKELY TO HAPPEN AND
THEN SOME FINAL THOUGHTS FOR
WHAT IT MEANS FOR THE BUSINESSES
AND UP THE CALIFORNIA.
ENTERING THE PRESIDENTIAL
PRIMARY SEASON.
I WANT TO BEGIN WITH QUOTES FROM
TWO PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATES.
FROM AMERICAN HISTORY SPEAKING
ABOUT THE PROMISE AND PERIL THE
NATIONAL TRADE HERE'S THE FIRST.
PIECE COMMERCE AN HONORS
FRIENDSHIP WITH ALL NATIONS
UNTANGLING ALLIANCES WITH NONE.
AND HERE'S THE SECOND.
SOONER OR LATER EVERY WORLD.
BECOMES A WAR OF BLOOD.
SO FOR OUR FOREBEARS THE CONDUCT
OF INTERNATIONAL TRADE WAS OWNED
UP WITH ISSUES OF ONE PIECE.
WHAT'S THE STUFF.
THE FIRST CALL WAS FOR SOMEONE
WHO ONE ELECTORAL VICTORY IN AND
WITH THE WHITE HOUSE OR FOR
SECRETARY OF STATE THOMAS
JEFFERSON.
THE SECOND LABOR LEADER EUGENE
DEBS LOST HIS BID FOR THE
PRESIDENCY A CENTURY LATER.
JEFF SAYS CONFLICTING VIEWS OF
INTERNATIONAL TRADE CAN BE
TRACED BACK TO THE BEGINNING OF
OUR PUBLIC.
CONCERNS ABOUT THE CURRENT WAVE
OF GLOBALIZATION AND CHINA'S
TRADE PRACTICES DIDN'T START
WITH THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
ALTHOUGH THE USE OF TARIFFS
ISN'T A NOVEL.
DURING MY RECENT TIME GOVERNMENT
FOR EXAMPLE YOUR ADMINISTRATION
BUT AN UNPRECEDENTED SIXTEEN
CASES AGAINST CHINA AT THE WORLD
TRADE ORGANIZATION.
OR WTO AND PRODDED BEIJING TO
ADDRESS THE OVER CAPACITY IN THE
STEEL AND ALUMINUM SECTORS.
THAT WERE UNDERMINING GLOBAL
MARKETS.
MAYBE SOME HISTORICAL
PERSPECTIVE MIGHT BE HELPFUL
HERE ON CHINA'S INTERNATIONAL
TRADE PRACTICES.
AFTER OVER A DECADE OF
NEGOTIATION WHEN THE U. S.
ALWAYS OFTEN IN THE LEAD TRY TO
JOIN THE WTO IN. TWO THOUSAND
ONE MOST DETAILED SET OF
REQUIREMENTS OF ANY NUMBER TO
POINT AT THAT TIME.
THE EXCEPTION PACKAGE IF YOU CAN
REDUCE TARIFFS. FOR IMPORTS OPEN
UP TRADING RIGHTS TO POP
COMPANIES.
AND REDUCE RESTRICTIONS ON
FOREIGN PARTICIPATION IN MANY
PARTS OF THE CHINESE ECONOMY.
WITH WTO MEMBERSHIP AND
INCENTIVES FOR FOREIGN
INVESTMENT INTO CHINA AND OF
COURSE THE ENTREPRENEURSHIP OF
THE CHINESE PEOPLE AND WORK
FORCE THE CHINESE ECONOMY GREW
FROM ABOUT TWO TRILLION DOLLARS
IN. TWO THOUSAND ONE TO NEARLY
ELEVEN TRILLION IN.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN ACCORDING TO THE
WORLD BANK PER CAPITA GDP WENT
FROM AROUND THREE THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN 200-012-18000 DOLLARS
LAST YEAR.
BUT JUST ONE PERSONAL NOTE.
AS SOMEONE WHO'S BEEN LIVING IN
CHINA ON AND OFF FOR TWENTY
YEARS WHEN I FIRST LIVED IN
CHINA IN THE EARLY NINETEEN
NINETIES.
THE MOST PRIZED COMMODITY COFFEE
BEANS BY FAR.
WORTH THEIR WEIGHT IN GOLD.
AND WHEN I LEFT BEIJING LAST
YEAR I WOULD SAY OUTSIDE THE US
EMBASSY GATE ONE BLOCK AWAY
THERE WERE FOR STARBUCKS WITHIN
WALKING DISTANCE -- AND FEAR NOT
FOR THOSE OF YOU HANKER FOR A
BAY AREA LOTS A IN CHINA TWENTY
SEVENTEEN PETE'S OPENED UP A
FLAGSHIP BRANCH IN SHANGHAI.
ALTHOUGH I HAVE TO SAY I HAVE
I'VE BEEN.
RETURNING TO OUR WTO STORY THE
CURRENT UNITED STATES TRADE
REPRESENTATIVE USTR LASSITER
PUBLIC HEISER.
HAS PUBLICLY FOR AS FAR BACK AS
TWENTY TWO AND THE VIEW THAT W.
TWO MEMBERS SHOULD NOT HAVE
ADMITTED CHINA IN.
TWO THOUSAND ONE AT THE MOST
MACRO LEVEL HIS CRITICISM.
THAT BY DROPPING STATE RESOURCES
AND LIMITING THE ACTS OF FOREIGN
FIRMS GOODS AND SERVICES. TO THE
DOMESTIC MARKET THE CHINESE
LEADERSHIP IS UNFAIRLY TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF AN OPEN GLOBAL
ECONOMY WHILE READING THIS TIME
AT HOME.
AND IN SPECIFIC SECTORS EVEN
WHEN THE U. S. HAS PREVAILED IN
WTO LITIGATION.
AB IN THE MARKET OFTEN HAS
REMAINED CLOSE TO PART COMPANY
FROM MY OWN EXPERIENCE IN TWO
CASES THAT THE U. S. ONE YEARS
AGO WHEN SECTORS IMPORTANT
CALIFORNIA.
ELECTRONIC PAYMENTS WHICH IS HE
IS A MASTER CARD AMERICAN
EXPRESS AND FILMS.
ACTUALLY GETTING LICENSES TO
OPERATE BASED ON WTO RULES AFTER
W. RULING HAS PROVEN DEVILISHLY
DIFFICULT.
I ALSO HAD DIFFERENT
EXPLANATIONS FOR THE LACK OF
LIBERALIZATION THE CHINESE
ECONOMY OVER A DECADE.
FROM IS TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
FINANCIAL CRISIS TO THE RISE OF
PRESIDENT XI JINPING.
BUT THE RESULT HAS BEEN THAT THE
VAST MAJORITY OF US COMPANIES
FEEL INCREASINGLY LESS WELCOME
IN CHINA.
WE NOW WITH US CHINA TRADE
FRICTION LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR DID
A GREAT JOB OF OF SETTING THE
GROUND WORK SO I WON'T COVER
THAT AGAIN HERE.
I WOULD JUST SAY AB AND IN
PARALLEL TO INCREASING TRADE ON
BOTH SIDES IT CAN CHRISTIAN
TERRACE EXCUSE ME ON BOTH SIDES.
AND INTERTWINED WITH THIS
NARRATIVE OF THE TO PROTECT
TERRACE.
IS A PORTAL DE COUPLING OF THE
U. S. AND CHINESE TECHNOLOGY
MARKETS WITH SOME OF TERM IN NEW
TECH COLD WAR.
AND THERE'S A COTTAGE INDUSTRY
IN WASHINGTON THESE DAYS YOU CAN
COME UP WITH WHAT THE RIGHT
PHRASE SHOULD BE OF US CHINA
TRADE FRICTION.
YOU'LL GET FAMOUS -- COOL WARS
ONE OF MY FAVORITES BUT A SERIES
OF CHINESE POLICIES OVER THE
LAST FIVE YEARS HAVE PROMOTED
DOMESTIC TECHNOLOGY PROCUREMENT.
TO THE DETRIMENT OF US PRODUCERS
FOR EXAMPLE IN TWENTY THIRTEEN
CHINESE BANKING REGULATOR EACH
ISSUED NEW RULES PHASING OUT
FOREIGN HARDWARE IN MOST NETWORK
AND IT APPLICATIONS.
IN APRIL TWENTY FOURTEEN JUMPING
ON HELPFULLY PUSHED A
NATIONALISTIC CYBERSECURITY
POSTURE AND THE TWENTY FIFTEEN
THE MADE IN CHINA TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE MANIFESTOS EXPLICIT
DOMESTIC MARKET GOALS.
IN TEN HIGH TECH SECTORS FROM
TRICK VEHICLES TO CLOUD
COMPUTING. FOR ITS PART UNITED
STATES AS THE TO READING CHINESE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS EQUIPMENT
COMPANIES CT AND HARD.
ON THE COMMERCE DEPARTMENT'S
CITIES LET LIMITING THEIR ACCESS
TO US COMPANIES FINANCING.
ZZ WAS ALLOWED TO RESUME
OPERATIONS WILL ALWAYS FATE
REMAINS UNCERTAIN.
ON THE INVESTMENT SIDE IN MARCH
THE TREASURY DEPARTMENT LED
COMMITTEE ON FOREIGN INVESTMENT
IN THAT IT STATES WERE SERVICE.
TOLL CHINESE GAMING COMPANY
QUINLAN TO UNWIND ITS TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
ACQUISITION OF THE GAY DATING UP
THERE AND APRIL SURFACE BLOCK MY
KNEES ACQUISITION.
THE U. S. HEALTHCARE PORTAL
PATIENTS LIKE ME.
BOTH OF THESE DECISIONS WERE
OFFICIALLY TAKEN.
ACT U. S. NATIONAL SECURITY.
REQUIRED BY THE RELEVANT STATUTE
WHICH IS KNOWN AS FROM.
ON THE TRADE TALKS WHERE THEY
SAID NOW.
THE NEXT LOGICAL STEP AS A
NUMBER OF YEARS OF SAID WOULD BE
FOR RESULT IN A FACE TO FACE
TALKS MY GUESS IS BEIJING WOULD
BE THE NEXT.
CITY I'VE BEEN AT THE PLACE OF
THE HOSTED -- PROBABLY THE
BEGINNING POINT WILL BE V.
HUNDRED FIFTY PAGE DRAFT THAT
THE TWO SIDES ARE WORKING ON
WHICH WOULD ADDRESS US MARKET
ACCESS CONCERNS.
INCLUDE A BASKET OF PURCHASES
AND CHIP AWAY AT SOME CHINESE
INDUSTRIAL POLICY CONCERNS IN
EXCHANGE THE TWO SIDES.
OF TERRACE ON EACH OTHER'S GOODS
THAT WOULD PRESUMABLY GRANT SOME
SORT OF LIFE FLIGHT TOOK AWAY
[INAUDIBLE]
THAT SAID.
WHATEVER AGREEMENT IS OR IS NOT
REACH BETWEEN THE US AND CHINESE
GOVERNMENTS IN THE COMING WEEKS
OR MONTHS.
BY TRADE AND DIPLOMATIC FRICTION
IS HERE TO STAY AS LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR SAID THIS IS NOT SIMPLY
A PHENOMENON OF THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION THAT WILL GO AWAY
IN TWO OR SIX YEARS.
IN WASHINGTON VIEW OF CHINA
AMONG THE POLITICAL CLASS.
BUSINESS LEADERS MILITARY
STRATEGISTS AND IN MANY PARTS OF
THE US GOVERNMENT BUREAUCRACY
HAS SHIFTED.
FROM THAT OF A DEVELOPING
COUNTRY NEEDING TO BE INTEGRATED
INTO THE GLOBAL ORDER TO A
PREDATORY STATE BACK ON UP UP
ENDING US LEADERSHIP.
FROM FIVE G. STANDARDS TO
NAVIGATION IN THE SOUTH CHINA
SEA.
FROM EXPORTING A MODEL OF A
BETTER TERM CAPITALISM TO THE
ONGOING CRACKDOWN IN XINJIANG
UYGUR AUTONOMOUS REGION JING'S
AMBITIOUS AMBITIONS AND METHODS.
ARE SEEN AS CONFLICTING WITH
LONG STANDING US GOALS IN THE
REGION ACROSS THE GLOBE.
SO.
LEAVE THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AS
A CASUAL OBSERVER WORKING.
THE US GOVERNMENT ON AND OFF FOR
THE LAST TWO DECADES IN CHINA I
WOULD SAY THAT CALIFORNIA BRAND
IN CHINA AS THE STRONGEST OF ANY
STATE THAT I'VE SEEN.
I THINK IT ALSO HELPS THAT IN
CHINESE YOU HAVE A VERY SIMPLE
WORD FOR CALIFORNIA SOME STATES
MY HOME STATE OF NEW JERSEY FOR
EXAMPLE EXTREMELY LONG NUMBER OF
CHINESE CHARACTERS.
IN THE IN CHINESE CALIFORNIA JOE
JOE'S JUST MUCH SIMPLER TO SAVE
AND SOME OTHER STATES -- I'VE
SEEN YOUR GOVERNOR'S TRIP WITH
HEAD OF STATE LIKE POMP AND
CIRCUMSTANCE DURING VISITS YOUR
UNIVERSITIES ARE SOUGHT AFTER.
BY THE BRIGHTEST MINDS YOUR
PROPERTY MARKETS OUR FAVORITE
DESTINATIONS FOR AND SPENT YOUR
TECHNOLOGIES COVETED.
INNOVATION SYSTEM IS CLOSELY
STUDY AND YOUR CULTURAL IMPACT
IS INDEED A FEW THOUGHTS
CONCLUDE.
FIRST.
CALIFORNIA COMPANIES AND
ENTREPRENEURS NEED TO BE ALIVE
TO THE OPPORTUNITIES IN CHINA.
BOTH IN TERMS OF SELLING ITS
MARKET AND ATTRACTING CHINESE
COUPLE HERE.
BUT IT WOULD BEHOOVE BUSINESSES
THE GOLDEN STATE. TO BE MINDFUL
OF THE RISING REGULATORY
STRUCTURE IN WASHINGTON DC
EXAMINING INBOUND IS INVESTMENT
AND MONITORING UP ON EXPORTS TO
CHINA.
THE US GOVERNMENT IS AT THE
MOMENT LOOKING AT TEN AREAS OF
WORK EMERGING TECHNOLOGIES FOR
ADDED SCRUTINY AND COMPANIES
OPERATING IN THOSE AREAS NEED TO
MOVE WITHOUT A CAUTION.
THOSE ARE IN THE AREA OF EXPORT
CONTROLS SECOND.
CALIFORNIA INDUSTRY AND
REPRESENTED TO SPEAK UP IN
WASHINGTON AND ACROSS THE US THE
LEGISLATIVE AND WILL MAKING
PROCESS REQUIRES PUBLIC INPUT AT
ANY DIFFERENT STAGES.
BEING PART OF THE CONVERSATION
WILL HELP INSURE CALIFORNIA'S
INTERESTS AND OUR BEST PROTECTED
SO SUBMIT TESTIMONY APPEAR
PUBLIC HEARINGS MAKE YOUR
COLLECTIVE VOICE HEARD.
UC BERKELEY CHAPTER CALLED
GHOSTS LETTER IN FEBRUARY
ELEGANTLY UP HELD THE VALUES OF
ACADEMIC OPEN.
AND ONE AGAINST DEMONIZING
AMERICANS OTHER CALIFORNIANS TO
SHE COULD DO THE SAME.
THIRDS PICKUP IN AN AS WELL THAT
IS FOR MARKET ACCESS CONCERNS OF
YOUR COMPANIES DO NOT SELL
CENTER A NUMBER OF FOLKS HAVE
MENTIONED THAT CHINA HAS FREE
TRADE AGREEMENTS WITH AUSTRALIA
AND CHILE AND CHILEAN WINE GETS
ENTER INTO THE FREE.
WELL CHINA COULD ENTERED COULD
CHANGE THE TIRE OF THAT HAS ON
ON U. S. ONE FOR EXAMPLE AND
DECIDED NOT TO DO THAT.
SO TO SPEAK UP FOR RESTRICTIONS
FOR TRYING FOR CALIFORNIA
EXPORTS OF SERVICES AND AT TRADE
FRICTION AND BROKE YOUR BROADER
GEOSTRATEGIC POSITIONING SHOULD
NOT LIMIT NORMAL COMMERCIAL
TRANSACTION OR EDUCATIONAL
EXCHANGES.
CIVIC INSTITUTIONS HAVE AND CAN
YOU TO PLAY AN IMPORTANT ROLE IN
CALIFORNIA ENGAGE WITH CHINA AND
WITH THE PACIFIC.
AMERICA IS A SPECIFIC MISSION
AND THESE TIES WILL CONTINUE TO
BEAR FRUIT FOR OUR COMPANIES ARE
UNIVERSITIES.
PEOPLE FOR DECADES TO COME WITH
THAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YOU MISTER GREEN BUT WE'RE VERY.
OF MY COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KANSEN CHU FROM SAN JOSE JOIN US
AS WELL AS I'M GOING TO ASK HIM
TO A FEW REMARKS.
GRAYSON -- THANK YOU VERY MUCH
CHAU YOU KNOW I APOLOGIZE.
THAT I MISSED THE FIRST PART OF
THE DOES HEARING FROM -- AND
NEXT TIME I WOULD DEFINITELY USE
OF PUBLIC TRANSIT. TO GET HERE
FROM SAN JOSE TO SAN FRANCISCO --
AND ONLY TOOK ME ABOUT TWO AND A
HALF HOURS SO BUT I WANT TO TAKE
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO THANK OUR
CHAIRPERSON PAYING. FOUR THOSE
HAVE THOSE HERE HEARING AND
SUCKED THE SAN FRANCISCO AND OUR
THE STATE'S LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR
AND COMES GENERAL A RENT AND AND
ALL RUBIO SPEAKER PHONE APART I
THINK THIS IS VERY.
THE HI BY THE TIME THE
DISCUSSION.
IN AND WE'LL WORKERS STILL UNDER
THE THE THOUGH CARLO BUT DOC
CLOTHS OVER THE TRADE WAR.
BUT THIS IS ALSO AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR US TO STRENGTHEN OUR
RELATIONSHIP.
BETWEEN A CALIFORNIA AND YOU AND
AND AND CHINA AND OTHER ASIAN
COUNTRY.
THE A JUST TOOK ON THE
GOVERNMENT TO GOVERNMENT SIDE
BUSINESS TO BUSINESS I AND THE
PEOPLE TO PEOPLE SIDE I'M SURE
THAT THE THE TREE WARD THE
CONFLICT WOULD BE OVER AND I MAY
BE.
HOPEFULLY SOONER THAN LATER AND
DOES A STRENGTHENING OUR
RELATION OF FOSTER OR RELATION
DOING JUST FINE I THINK WILL
YIELD A VERY VERY GOOD RETURN
ONE TO TRADE WARS IT IS OVER SO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOU YOUR
YOUR PRESENCE AND YOUR INTEREST
IN THIS TOPIC AS WELL THANK YOU.
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER SO.
MR GREEN ENDED ON A NOTE OF WHAT
WHAT CALIFORNIA CAN DO IN TERMS
OF STICKING OUT BEING -- THEIR
ADVOCATES IN WASHINGTON AS WELL
AS WITH MANY OF OUR BUSINESS --
GROUPS JUST WIDE OPEN UP TO THE
PANEL TO ASK.
WHAT ELSE COULD CALIFORNIA DO
ABOUT DEL SHOULD SHOULD
CALIFORNIA REALLY DO IN THIS
SITUATION KNOWING THAT OBVIOUSLY
WE DON'T?
OF ANY -- WE ARE NOT THE ONE IN
CHARGE OF THE TRIP POLICY BUT
HOW DO THAT WHAT WHICH SHOULD BE
INAPPROPRIATE. FOR OUR STATE.
WELL AS CEMENTING HAPPY GO FIRST
AT I THINK AB PROFESSOR GREEN.
GOOD AT WAITED IS IT WHICH IS
SPEAKING OUT.
AND THERE ARE A COUPLE PLACES
THAT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
OUR VOICES HEARD ONE IS MOST
CERTAINLY IN WASHINGTON DC.
AND MY OFFICE IS HAVING REGULAR
CONVERSATIONS WITH OUR
CALIFORNIA DELEGATION OUR
CONGRESSIONAL DELEGATION.
I'M HAVING STORIES IS VERY
HELPFUL HAVING DATA IS VERY
HELPFUL VERY OFTEN DATA LAGS.
IN THE ACTUAL IMPACTS THAT
COMPANIES AND CONSUMERS ARE FEET
LÏNG SO TO THE DEGREE TO WHICH
PEOPLE IN THIS ROOM.
PEOPLE WHO PARTICIPATE HERE
TODAY HAVE -- ANECDOTES AND DATA.
PLEASE SEND TO OUR OFFICES
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR'S OFFICE THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE A BUSINESS AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AS WELL --
THIS IS IT'S EASY TO FIND US
ONLINE.
AND DIE THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT AS
WE ARE COLLECTING INFORMATION IN
ORDER TO HAVE DATA BEFORE WE
HAVE TO WAIT FOR THAT KIND OF
LONGER PROCESS THAT FINISHED AT
AND THAT'S ONE THING AND SO THE
OTHER THING THOUGH I DO THINK
HAS IT IT HAS BEEN ALLUDED TO IN.
KIND OF DANCED AROUND A LITTLE
BIT.
AND I MENTIONED IT IS BUT IT IS
VERY.
REAL PART OF THIS EQUATION WHICH
IS THAT FOR A LONG TIME NOW
CALIFORNIA COMPANIES AND
COMPANIES.
HAVE BEEN COMPLETE MEANING ABOUT
THE STRENGTHS THAT THEY HAVE
ENCOUNTERED IN DOING BUSINESS IN
CHINA AND I'M I UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT.
RECIPROCITY IS SOMETHING THAT
THE CHINESE AND CHINESE CULTURE
IS VERY MUCH VALUED.
OUR SYSTEM IS VERY OPEN TO
CHINESE INVESTMENT.
OUR COMPANIES AS THEY ENDEAVOR
TO DO BUSINESS CHINA -- HAVE
FACE VERY SERIOUS CONSTRAINTS
SENT OUT I KNOW DEPUTY CONSUL
GENERAL SAID THERE VOLUNTARILY
THERE YES THEY ARE VOLUNTARILY
THERE BUT THEY ARE NOT ALWAYS
VOLUNTARILY AT LEAST WHAT I
WOULD CALL VOLUNTARILY.
ABSENT NEEDING TO THE
CONSTRAINTS SO -- US COMPANIES
CAN AFFORD TO COMPANIES GOD I
WILL TALK ABOUT THESE THINGS
OFTEN BEHIND CLOSED DOORS NOT
NECESSARILY INTERESTED IN
PUBLICIZING THEIR COMPLAINTS
ABOUT SOME OF THAT -- SOME OF
THE THE BARRIERS AND SOME OF THE
THINGS THEY'VE BEEN FORCED TO DO
IF THEY WANT TO OPERATE IN CHINA.
I'M BECAUSE THEY DON'T WANT TO
ROCK THE BOAT THEY WANT TO TRY
TO WORK IT OUT FOR THEMSELVES
WELL I THINK IT'S REACHED A HEAD
AND I THINK THAT AS A CHINA IT
REALLY.
HAS NOT JUST YOU KNOW HAD THIS
ARC OF MATURITY IN THERE ARE
INTERNATIONAL TRADE DEALINGS BUT
NOW ARE A FULL FULL HEDGED
OBVIOUSLY MEMBER OF THE
INTERNATIONAL.
A COMMUNITY THAT RECOGNIZING ON
THAT.
THAT NEGOTIATING ROUNDS SOME OF
THE BARRIERS THAT US COMPANIES
HAVE COUNTERED IS SOMETHING THAT
WILL.
ULTIMATELY LEAD US TO A FRIENDLY
RESOLUTION AT THIS CURRENT
CONFLICT AND I HOPE.
THAT BECAUSE OF NATURE I LIVE
CALIFORNIA AND AT THE WAY THAT
WE HAVE TRULY THIS SPECIAL
RELATIONSHIP I BELIEVE.
I BETWEEN EUROPE THIS SUB
NATIONAL LEVEL AT WHICH
PROFESSOR GREEN ALLUDED TO YOU
KNOW.
THAT OUR PERCEPTION OUR OUR
CULTURE AT OPENNESS AS A SOCIETY.
OUR ATTRACTIVE YES STUDENTS FROM
CHINA WHICH WE HAVE A VERY LARGE
PERCENTAGE.
HEIDI'S NATIONALS CURRENTLY OR
IN OUR UC SYSTEM FOR INSTANCE
AND MEETING WHICH ACTUALLY THE
UC REGENTS IS MEETING I ACTUALLY
HAVE TO GET GOING OVER THERE
SOON -- BUT I HOPE THAT AS PART
OF THAT PART OF THAT
CONVERSATION WHICH REALLY IS
GOING TO BE A MAJOR PIECE.
OF MOVING THIS ALONG.
AND GETTING BACK TO LOWERING AT
THE TERRORISTS ON BOTH SIDES I
HOPE THAT.
CALIFORNIA COMPANIES AND
INTERLOCUTORS WE'LL BE ABLE TO
FIND OUT IF I TO SEAT AT THE
TABLE ON THE FEDERAL SIDE AT
LEAST.
UNSEAT SOMEWHERE AT A CHAIR IN
THE ROOM TO BE ABLE TO HELP THAT
PART OF THE PROCESS ALONG.
THANK YOU LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR
ALSO THANKS SO MUCH SPENDING SO
MUCH TIME WITH US TODAY.
SO SO IT SOUNDS LIKE PARTICULAR
NOT ONLY DO WE HER.
LOWER THE TERRORIST WE NEED TO
ENSURE THAT WE'RE GOING.
ON BOTH SIDES TO DOING BUSINESS.
CALIFORNIA AND YOU IT'S DOESN'T
HAVE A LOT OF BARRIERS ENTRY FOR
FOREIGN DIRECT INVESTMENT.
I'M THAT IS A KEY PROVISION OF
YOU KNOW HISTORICALLY OF US
TRADE WE WELCOME FOREIGN DIRECT
INVESTMENT AND WE OFFER A LEVEL
PLAYING FIELD. TO FOREIGN
COMPANIES ALONG WITH US
COMPANIES HERE I IT'S WHY WE ARE
SO ATTRACTIVE ONE OF THE REASONS
ONE OF THE MANY REASONS WHY THE
UNITED STATES IS IT ATTRACTIVE
TO FOREIGN DIRECT INVESTMENT.
SO MY HOPE IS THAT.
THIS SAYS WILL BE SEEN AS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR CHINA. TO
RECOGNIZE THAT OPENING UP EVEN
MORE I'M IS SOMETHING THAT
ULTIMATELY WILL BE CAUGHT I FOR
THE NINETIES ECONOMY AND FRANKLY.
I'M WILL LET AGAIN AS THE CONSUL
GENERAL MENTION DEVELOP THESE
TRADE RELATIONSHIPS WHICH
ULTIMATELY.
AS FORM AND BASIS OF COOPERATION
COLLABORATION FRIENDSHIP AND
MUTUAL UNDERSTANDING I WHICH
WILL BE TO THE BENEFIT OF OUR
GENERATION AND FUTURE
GENERATIONS AS WELL [INAUDIBLE]
THEY SO -- TO CHOP YOU YOU
HIGHLIGHTED.
THERE ARE IN LOS ANGELES A LOT
OF THE ISSUES AROUND --
MANUFACTURING OUR HOUSE
DISTRIBUTION.
MAYBE YOU COULD TALK A LITTLE.
MORE ABOUT ONE SUCH MORE
SPECIFIC IMPACTS BUT ALL OF
REALLY WHAT WILL BE COULD BE IN
BECAUSE THE THOSE ARE.
WORKING CLASS JOBS THAT WE COULD
EASILY BE THE LOSER.
SO -- I ACTUALLY WANTED TO GET
BACK OF WHAT THE LEAGUE HAD
GOVERNOR WAS SAYING THIS WELL --
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES TO
MANUFACTURING ONE OF THE KEY
SECTORS THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
GROW IN LOS ANGELES IS A CLEAN
TECHNOLOGY SECTOR -- GIVEN THAT
LOS ANGELES IN CALIFORNIA HAS
SOME OF THE MOST STRINGENT
ENVIRONMENTAL REGULATIONS IN THE
WORLD WE DON'T SHY AWAY FROM WE
STEP UP WHEN THE PRESIDENT
WALKED AWAY FROM THE PARIS
CLIMATE AGREEMENTS.
THE CALIFORNIA AND THE LOS
ANGELES REGION.
BASICALLY SAID WE'RE GONNA
DOCTOR ARE OF THAT THE PAST KIND
OF GREEN ON THEIR OWN ACCORD AND
WITH THAT WE ACTUALLY DO NOT
STOP TO TALK WEEK CREATED
PROGRAMS WE CAN ACTUALLY -- AT
HERE TO THESE RELATIONS
ENVIRONMENTAL REGULATION
INCLUDING LOS ANGELES CITIES OWN
CLEAN -- GREEN NEW DEAL AS WELL
A SOMETHING CALLED THE CLEANER
ACTION PLAN THAT PORTABLE SENDS
AS PART OF LONG BEACH WHERE
THEY'RE GOING TO BE REDUCING BY
MENTAL -- POLLUTION WHILE
INCREASING POOR ACTIVITIES.
AND THESE ARE.
BACKED BY A FUNDING -- BOTH FROM
THE PORT OF LOS ANGELES AND TO
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO THE
CAR MY LOOK MORE PROGRAMS AND
OTHER GRANTS AS WELL.
NOW WE'RE CREATING BRANIEWO
TECHNO G. AND INCLUDING SHORTS I
PLUG IN TECHNOLOGY --
ELECTRIFICATION OF THE PORTS --
ELECTRIC HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS THAT
ARE ABLE TO MOVE -- OUR CARGO TO
AND FROM LOS ANGELES REGION.
WHAT BETTER WAY?
AREA OR COUNTRY TO EXPORT OUR
PRODUCTS AND TO CHINA AND WE'RE
REALLY EAGER TO DO SO HOWEVER
WITH SUCH AN ALLERGY WHETHER
IT'S REAL OR WHETHER IT'S BURNED --
OR JUST SPECULATED A LOT OF OUR
COMPANIES ARE VERY WARY ABOUT
GOING INTO CHINA.
WHICH FOR US AS THE ONE THAT ONE
ROAD STRATEGIES MOVING FORD IS
GOING CONNECTS SO MANY DIFFERENT
MARKETS SO HAVING A PARTNER AND
CHINA TO BE ABLE TO HELP US GET
ACCESS.
AND BE ABLE TO UNDERSTAND THAT
THESE COMPANIES WHETHER YOU'RE A
MULTI NATIONAL CONGLOMERATE OR
SMALL.
AND MEDIUM SIZE FROM LOS ANGELES
YOU HAVE EQUAL ACCESS EQUAL
FOOTING WILL BE VERY VERY
HELPFUL AND I KNOW THAT CHINA'S
ARTI MOVING FORWARD WITH
CHANGING SOME OF THE POLICIES IN
TERMS OF AND IP PROTECTION.
AND THAT WHAT WILL BE GREAT ALSO
IS TO LOOK AT ENFORCEMENT SIDE
AS WELL AND ALSO THE
COMMUNICATION BACK TO OUR REGION
SO WE UNDERSTAND CLEARLY HOW TO
ACCESS THAT MARKET.
AND THIS IS AGAIN TIED BACK INTO
MANUFACTURING BECAUSE WE ARE NOW
WILL BE MOVING FORWARD WITH THE
PROGRAMS LIKE THE CLEAN ASIDE
THE LOSS I JUST THINK I CAN GET
BETTER -- WE'RE PUTTING CITY
RESOURCES AND AND REGIONAL
RESPONSES INTO IT AND ONCE THESE
COMPANIES ARE READY TO GO WERE
REALLY BEING THAT CHINA WILL BE
ONE OF THE MAJOR PARKS.
GREAT THANK YOU.
I MISSED YOU YOU YOU MENTIONED --
OF THE INTEREST OF CHINA
COMPANIES COMING TO SAVE IT BUT
ALSO TO THE BAY AREA THERE BEEN
IMPACTS SINCE THE WAR ON ALL OF
THAT INTEREST IF YOU SEEN ANY
KIND OF DAMPENING OF OF THANK
YOU SO.
MUCH ASSEMBLYMAN TING FOR THE
QUESTION IS A REALLY QUESTION
AND TO BE QUITE HONEST -- I HAVE
NOT SEEN OF A WALL IN AND DAY I
THINK THAT THERE ARE A LOT LESS
BUT I'D WITH CALLED TIRE KICKERS
COMING THROUGH A TOWN NOW.
STIRS CONTINUED A COMMA AND WHEN
WE DO SPEAK TO INVESTORS.
THEY ACTUALLY DO HAVE THE MONEY
AND THEY'RE READY TO GO -- AND
THEY'RE NOT AFRAID -- TO PIGGY
BACK ALSO AND ON WHAT THE
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR SAID IN WHAT
STEVEN SAID I'D ALSO LIKE TO SAY
THAT -- EDUCATION IS REALLY
IMPORTANT ESPECIALLY FOR INBOUND
INVESTORS -- AND ONE ONE TOPIC
THAT IS OF MAJOR CONCERN AND I'M
SURE.
THE PROFESSOR COULD ALSO CONFIRM
AS FIFTY AS HAS BEEN THE BIG
ISSUE ESPECIALLY FOR AN INBOUND
INVESTMENT WHETHER YOU'RE GOING
TO BE GOING TO EMMA NAY WHETHER
CAN HE FOR TECH COMPANY.
OR EVEN MANUFACTURING OR EVEN
REAL ESTATE -- BUT THE THING IS
THAT WHAT WE STILL HAVE LEARNED
IS THAT FOR MY EXPERIENCE I'VE
SEEN LESS THAN ONE OUT OF TEN
COMPANIES ACTUALLY BEING STOPPED --
BECAUSE OF THE PS RULES --
WHEREAS YOU KNOW IF THESE
COMPANIES WHO ARE LOOKING TO
INVEST IN THE US IF THEY ARE
ACTUALLY BEING EDUCATED OR THEY
TALK TO MORE PEOPLE
COMMUNICATION IS KEY.
THE MORE THEY LEARN THE MORE
PEOPLE THEY TALK TO THEY WILL
FEEL MORE COMFORTABLE AND AGAIN
CALIFORNIA IS DEFINITELY OPEN
FOR BUSINESS I TELL EVERYONE
WE'RE PROBABLY ONE OF THE MOST
OPEN STATES IN THE IN THE NATION --
BUT THE THING IS ONCE ONCE THESE
FOREIGN COMPANIES UNDERSTAND
THAT FIFTY IS IS AN ISSUE YOU
SHOULD DECLARE.
AND ACTUALLY A TEACH THEM HOW TO
GO THROUGH THE PROCESS IT WILL
MAKE -- I THINK IN DOWN
INVESTORS FEEL MORE COMFORTABLE
WHEN THEY'RE COMING TO YOU WITH
GREAT THANK YOU -- IT IN. FOR
YOU YOU TALKED A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT -- REALLY THE IMPORTANCE
IN CALIFORNIA IN CHINA.
WHAT DO YOU THINK WE SHOULD BE
DOING IN TERMS OF -- RIDLEY ARE
WITHIN THIS GREAT WAR.
HOW WE AT THE STATE SHOULD BE
ACTING -- I AGREE WITH THANK YOU --
PHILIP NOW AND I AGREE WITH
THREATEN GUN AND I AND OTHERS
SPEAKERS DODD TO COMMUNICATION
THERE'S A VERY IMPORTANT ON THE
RIGHT TO OUR VOICE.
BE HEARD AND CALIFORNIA FRIENDS
WISE BE HEARD BY BOWS WASHINGTON
AND BEIJING.
YEAH -- INCLUDING THE
ENVIRONMENTAL OF YOU THAT'S THE
MEANT WE KNOW THAT WE ARE NOT
PERFECT.
CHINA -- A FEW DAYS AGO I MEANT
TO THE CELL PRESIDENTE CABLES
ALL OF SHANGHAI -- ABOUT CHAMBER
THEY ALSO RAISES THE THEY USED
TO ALL FOR MASTERCARD -- THE
VISA CARD AND OPEN A SOUL FOUGHT
CHINA AS FINANCIAL MARKET -- ON
THE MOVIE.
CONSULATE GENERAL HERE IS ALSO A
CHANNEL WE WILL REPORT TO AND SO.
DIFFERENT CHINA -- TO WASHINGTON
TO BEIJING MORE COMMUNICATION A
LADY AT HAVE A BETTER HONEST
NATURE.
AS MENTIONED THE BY -- MY
COLLEAGUES TO ME.
GREEN AS CLOSE TOGETHER IN
BEIJING.
BY THAT TIME THE STRATEGIC ON
THE MAP ECONOMIC A DIALOGUE.
IT'S A VERY GOOD SO MÙT
COMMUNICATION -- WITH EACH OTHER
AND DIALOGUE.
LEGAL.
FOURTEEN GREAT THANK YOU.
THE MYSTERY YOU DUE TO THE
LITTLE ABOUT.
WE COULD.
BE IN CALIFORNIA.
WHAT DO YOU MEAN THIS CALL SIR
AND ABOUT IF THIS -- DOESN'T
RESOLVED ANYTIME SOON.
THANK YOU AGAIN WHAT WHAT IT WAS.
WE KNOW WHAT'S WHAT ARE THE
STAKES FOR CALIFORNIA.
IS A MEMBER TING THANKS AGAIN
VERY MUCH AND I JUST WANNA SAY
AS SOMEONE WHO'S BEEN A DIPLOMAT
ONSTAGE HAVING HIS.
CHINESE THANK YOU A DIFFICULT
STRUGGLE RUN IT'S IT'S ALWAYS
HARD TO DO -- TO IT REPRESENT
YOUR COUNTRY IN A FOREIGN
LANGUAGE SO THANKS FOR DOING
THIS IN ENGLISH -- MAYBE I COULD
HAVE A YEAR AGO -- I THINK THE
THE BROADER CHALLENGE IT OFF ON
THE CURRENT TRADE FRICTIONS THAT
IT.
MORPHED INTO SOMETHING MUCH
LARGER THAT IT.
WITH THE F. B. I. EMPOWERED TO
GO AFTER WHAT THEY SEE AS THEFT
OF US INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY OR
AFTER CHINESE AMERICANS I THINK
THAT'S THE BIGGEST -- KIND OF
BROADER TRUMPS THE UNITED STATES
IN US SOCIETY.
I THINK ON THE ECONOMIC SIDE.
IN THIS CURTAILING OF INVESTMENT
ACROSS BOTH -- BUT ACROSS THE
PACIFIC IS IS GOING TO BE WHAT
FARMS -- IN SOME WAYS MAYBE EVEN
MORE THAN TERRACE AND I THINK
THEY'RE OTHER ODDS OF HIS
CONCERNS AND I THINK THE US
NEEDS TO BE ALERT TO THEM AS I
SAID.
BUT I THINK THE ONCE INVESTMENT
PATTERNS REALLY CHANGE OVER YEAR
SOME PEOPLE THINK WELL I DON'T
KNOW ONE INVEST IN CALIFORNIA --
EITHER ONE OF US THE UNITED
STATES I'M GONNA GO TO NEW
ZEALAND OR AUSTRALIA THEN I
THINK ONCE THAT MIND SETS WHICH
IS THAT THAT'S THAT'S QUITE
DANGEROUS.
YEAH THE END AND AS YOU HAD
MENTIONED BEFORE.
THE WHOLE THING ABOUT.
WHEN IS?
AND IN CHINA THAT IS STRONG NOT
ONLY IS CALIFORNIA'S BRIGHT
TRONG.
THE BRAND OF OUR CITIES
FRANCISCO CHANGED.
THOSE ARE ALL SEEN AS
DESTINATION PLACES FOR
INVESTMENT.
IN A YOU KNOW WE'RE NOT ONLY CAN
THINK AGAIN THE COUNTRIES WERE
COMPETING AGAINST OTHER STATES
TO SOMETHING THAT IS.
ALSO A CHALLENGE THAT WE ALL
FACE THAT IT ARE.
STATE A FAR.
THAT THERE'S PLENTY OF OTHER
PEOPLE WILL TURN.
STEPPED IN TO THAT.
I KNOW THAT THAT WAS MY OPEN TO
ONE OF THE PUBLIC TO KIND OF
HAPPEN OPINIONS OR ANY.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
PUBLIC WE HAVE A MICROPHONE.
ANYBODY WANTS.
TO SAVE.
WE HAVE OUR OUR CAT WOMAN FROM
MILLBRAE WAY MUCH INTRODUCE
YOURSELF.
GOOD MORNING.
MY NAME IS -- MERRILL WAYNE FROM
THIS CITY NO BREAK.
WE ARE AS A CAT.
LOOKING INTO FORMING A TRADE
OFFICE -- FOR REPORTERS WITHOUT
THE CONSULTATION WITH A LESSER
THANK YOU TONY.
AND SO TURN CAN MAYBE WE CAN
TAKE TURNS AWAY BUT WE CAN ALSO
PROVIDE.
ECONOMIC INCENTIVES.
TAX BREAKS.
AND OTHER TYPE OF THINGS THAT WE
COULD DO TO HELP CHINESE ARE
GOOD SIR OUR BUSINESS IS. TO
PERFORM IN CALIFORNIA -- ONE
THING ABOUT THE BAY AREA MOSTLY
IS THAT DIFFERENT FROM LOS
ANGELES AT WIMBERLEY SERVICE
BASED.
SO I'M WONDERING HOW THAT
AFFECTS.
OUR SERVICE BASED ECONOMY IN
CHINA AND AROUND THE WORLD.
THERE'S A SHIFTED TO DIFFERENT
COUNTRIES THIS ISSUE AND AND AND
WHY HEARD WAS ALARMING IS THAT.
SOME COMPANIES TO STOP PRODUCING.
PRODUCTS THAT ALSO INCLUDES
SERVICES THANK YOU.
GREAT ANYBODY WANNA.
JUMP IN I COULD TRY TO TAKE A
STAB AT THE TERROR OF QUICK IN --
AND I THINK IT'S FOR IT IF I
COULD HAVE A KIND OF TERROR FREE
ZONE. ONE OF THE HALLMARKS OF
THE WTO WHICH THE UNITED STATES
SET UP AFTER WORLD WAR TWO FIRST
IN THE GENERAL AGREEMENT ON
TARIFFS AND TRADE GATT AND THE
WTO WAS.
THIS IDEA THAT COUNTRIES SHOULD
NOT DISCRIMINATE ON TERRORISTS
FROM OTHER COUNTRIES THERE
SHOULD BE MOST FAVORED NATION
WHICH JUST MEANS A NORMAL HER
FLAVEL.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT THE
SECTION THREE ONE TERRACE DO
THAT THIS ADMINISTRATION IS ON
IS AGAINST THE RULES OF THE WTO
AND SO THOSE WTO RULES PROHIBIT
CHINA SAYING.
CALIFORNIA ALMONDS WILL HAVE
ZERO TARIFF PERCENTAGE FOR YOU
BUT ALMONDS FROM OTHER COUNTRIES
WE'RE GONNA KEEP IT HIGH UNLESS
THERE'S AN EXCEPTION FOR A FREE
TRADE AGREEMENT SO THAT'S WHY
CHILEAN WINE.
AND AUSTRALIAN LIKE IT'S COME
INTO THE FREEZER SENATE'S HIGHER
FREE TRADE AGREEMENT.
SO UNLESS THE US AND CHINA HAD A
FREE TRADE AGREEMENT WE COULDN'T
KIND OF BRING THE STARS DOWN. TO
ZERO I THINK THE THE OF THE
OTHER AREA THAT YOU COULD LOOK
AT IS ON INVESTMENT THAT IS
OFTEN TIMES A TRADE INVESTMENT
KIND OF GO HAND IN HAND YOU HAVE
A PROCESSING FACILITY THAT'S
PROCESSING ALMONDS.
AND IF YOU INVEST IN THAT THAT
HELPS THE SALE OF IT AND SO.
ARE.
ABOUT CHANGING RESTRICTIONS ON
INVESTMENT I THINK SOME OF THE
CHINESE I COULD LOOK AT AND ON
OUR SIDE WE DON'T REALLY HAVE
RESTRICTIONS ON INVESTMENT SO IT
WOULD HAVE TO BE SOMETHING MAYBE
MORE SYMBOLIC ON THE CALIFORNIA
SOUGHT BUT THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
YOU COULD LOOK AT ALL.
ON INVESTMENT ZONES.
RIGHT OTHER OTHER QUESTIONS OR
THOUGHTS THE AUDIENCE
[INAUDIBLE]
HELLO.
THANKS EVERYONE.
MATCHING I RESEARCH CHINA
CALIFORNIA RELIGIONS THE
QUESTION FOR LIEUTENANT THAT ARE
SPECIFICALLY ON THE KEY ROLE OF
THE STATE BERMAN AT WITH
TECHNOLOGY RELATIONS.
I THINK THAT YOU KNOW HIM SO
VALUABLE THE COMPANIES ARE
RELIEVED NATIONAL AND GLOBAL
COMPANIES AND SO THEIR RELATIONS
WITH CHINA OFTEN ESCALATE VERY
MUCH TO THE NATIONAL LEVEL OR
THE KIND OF RUNNING THEIR OWN
DIPLOMACY SOMETIMES.
I'M WONDERING WHETHER YOU THINK
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA STATE GOVERNMENT HAS
A ROLE TO PLAY IN HELPING
NEGOTIATOR OR WORK OUT THAT
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN.
CALIFORNIA BASED COMPANIES
GOOGLE FACEBOOK WHATNOT AND THE
CHINESE GOVERNMENT AND CHINESE
MARKET ACCESS AND RESTRICTIONS.
SO THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION --
I'VE BEEN IN MY JOB FOR SIX
MONTHS WE HAVE A NEW GOVERNOR IN
CALIFORNIA GOVERNOR NEWSOME
MOVES MAYOR.
OF SAN FRANCISCO WHO HAS VERY
CLOSE -- RELATIONSHIPS WITH THAT
TECH COMPANIES MANY OF WHICH ARE
LOCATED IN THE CITY THAT HE WAS
MAYOR -- BUT ALSO HE WROTE A
BOOK ABOUT THE IMPACTS OF AT
TECHNOLOGY ON THE PUBLIC SQUARE
DEMOCRACY TRYING TO READ WAS
CALLED -- SOMETHING MARKETS
GERMAN ANYWAY OUT BUT IT IS BY
THE CITIZENS OF CITIZEN DAHLE
THANK YOU.
I'M AND SO I THE REASON THAT I'M
SITTING HERE IN THIS CAPACITY IS
THAT HE SIGNED AN EXECUTIVE
ORDER DESIGNATING ME HE
REPRESENTATIVE FOR INTERNATIONAL
AFFAIRS.
WE'VE NEVER DONE ANYTHING LIKE
IT BEFORE HE ALSO ESTABLISH AN
INTER AGENCY COMMITTEE WE USED
TO HAVE A DEPARTMENT OF COMMERCE
FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA HE
WAS ELIMINATED IN TWO THOUSAND
FOUR KIND OF A LONG STORY.
BUT THE WORK HAS NOT GONE AWAY
AND WHAT'S HAPPENED IS THAT
REGION'S LIKE LOS ANGELES I MEAN.
NO THIS PRESENTATION TODAY I
THINK CLEARLY EXEMPLIFIES THE
THE ENGAGEMENT OF LA IN
INTERNATIONAL TRADE AND
INVESTMENT I'M SAN DIEGO HAS
SIMILAR INFRASTRUCTURE BAY AREA
BERRY COUNSELED DURING THESE
GROUP.
HERE AS WELL -- THERE'S A LOT OF
THIS REGIONAL ACTIVITY THAT'S
KIND OF TAKEN THE PLACE OF THE
STATE ROLL.
I'M.
BUT THERE IS AN ENORMOUS AMOUNT
OF WORK THAT STATE TILT CELL
DOES I WILL TELL YOU A LOT OF IT.
IS HAS BEEN NOW OVER THE LAST
DECADE PLUS AROUND THE CLIMATE
AGENDA.
I'M AT THE SUB NATIONAL LEVEL
THE STATE HAS A LOT MORE MORE
ROOM TO ROAM MANEUVER AND SAT
POLICY -- AS WELL AS DO
MISSIONAL EXCHANGES AND I THAT
KIND OF WORK.
I'M SO WE ARE IN THE PROCESS OF
REALLY ATTEMPTING TO ANSWER THE
QUESTION THAT YOU ASKED WITH
FULL RESPECT OF THE FACT THAT
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS
JURISDICTION HERE ON THINGS LIKE
SETTING TERRACE.
I'M AND THEN OF COURSE RAISING
OUR VOICES.
THANK HEY WE AGREE BROUGH WE
AGREE WE NEED ACTION -- IN
RESPONSE TO THE FREE A ONE
DECISIONS I AND WE WANT TO BE
PART OF THAT.
CONVERSATION.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME THE WAY THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION HAS GONE
ABOUT THIS IS THEY'VE CREATED
THE PRESSURE BY -- BY PUTTING
THE TERRORISTS IN PLACE.
BUT WE ARE OVER A YEAR INTO THIS
AND THERE HASN'T BEEN.
ANY MEANINGFUL AND AT LEAST ANY
REPORTED MEANINGFUL I ADVANCES
IN THIS CONVERSATION NOW AGAIN
WE HEAR ANECDOTALLY THERE ARE
MEETINGS THAT ARE GOING ON EVEN
THIS WEEK. TO TRY TO MOVE THE
CONVERSATION FORWARD BY -- TWO
IN THE MEANTIME.
IT'S IT'S AFFECTING US IN A VERY
SERIOUS WAY IN NOT.
YOU KNOW AND SPECIFICALLY IN
TECHNOLOGY IS ALL.
SO WE'RE WORKING ON IT.
GET YOU GET QUESTIONS OVER HERE
[INAUDIBLE]
HI.
AND THAT FROM A DIXIE BUT AND
I'M CO CHAIR OF A GLOBAL.
YEAH WE HAVE HER DAY SOME OF THE
BETWEEN THE US AND CHINA FROM A
NATIONAL LEVEL.
I THINK THERE'S A LOT OF
OPPORTUNITY AS WE GO FARTHER
DOWN AND HAVE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA BEING GAUGED -- AND
THEN CITY TO CITY INVOLVEMENT I
THINK WE ALSO HAVE TO REMEMBER
THAT THERE NEEDS TO BE PEOPLE TO
PEOPLE ENGAGEMENTS ARE WE CAN'T
FORGET THAT I THINK THE MOST
IMPORTANT HOW YOU KNOW WHERE WE
SEE -- SOME OF THE GREATEST
GAINS IN TERMS OF OPENING DOORS
IS WHEN STUDENTS COME AND STUDY.
FROM CHINA INTO THE US AND U. S.
STUDENTS GO TO STUDY -- IN CHINA
I THINK THAT'S THE YOU KNOW THE
DIALOGUE WE HAVE TO CONTINUE
TOURISM HAS TO CONTINUE SO I
THINK WE NEED TO BUILD THE BONDS
OF THE PEOPLE TO PEOPLE.
AND THE YOU KNOW THE BUSINESS
WILL TAKE CARE OF ITSELF AND
FRANKLY I FEEL THAT THE ECONOMIC
LARGER YOU KNOW BY NATIONALLY
EIGHT INCH TAKE CARE OF
THEMSELVES SO I THINK IF WE
FOCUS ON PEOPLE -- YOU KNOW
EVERYTHING WILL WORK OUT IN THE
END [INAUDIBLE]
THANK YOU.
MORNING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [INAUDIBLE]
TO ASSEMBLYMEMBER TANK.
AND AND THE CHILDREN HEY TO ALL.
PARTICIPATE THIS.
ONE MY NAME'S HIM MADE HIM.
A WAS SO.
CAN COMMISSIONER FOR ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT.
DURING THE YEAR. TO TWENTY TEN
AND TWENTY THIRTEEN APPOINTED BY
PULLED GOVERNOR SCHWARZENEGGER
THE GOVERNOR BROWN [INAUDIBLE]
AND HI AM I BEING HEAVILY
INVOLVED.
IN THE CAN NO CHINA TRAINING
SINCE.
NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE MAKE ABOUT
OVER ONE HUNDRED TRIPS TO CHINA
DURING THIS.
LAST FOUR YEARS.
ALL WELL REALIZE THAT WHEN YOU
THIS SOLUTION -- TO SOLVE THIS.
AND THE ARE LIKE.
TO REQUEST A EXTRA OVER HERE.
THERE MAY BE ALL THE ALTERNATE.
IN ADDITION TO OF COURSE GIVEN
THE PRESSURE.
TO COME UP TO YOU A WERE PRESSED
ON TO US YES OFFICE OR SCHOOL TO
LAW.
WHO OF COURSE THIS ASSUMES
POSSIBLE [INAUDIBLE]
SO MY SUGGESTION A PROPOSAL WILL
BE BASED ON ANOTHER SIMILAR.
CASE BACK TO THE YEAR.
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN THE ON
DECEMBER NINTH -- I WAS INVITED
BY.
STATE ASSEMBLY TO GIVE THE
PUBLIC SPEAKING.
LIKE THIS ONE AT THAT TIME THE
CASE WAS WAS MUCH SMALLER SCALE.
IT WAS IN THE SOLAR PANEL --
DISPUTE BACK TO THAT TIME.
CAN FOUR S..
THAT'S ALL ASKING 43522100%.
OF X. LARA IMPORT DO ONTO THE
SOLAR RELATED PRODUCTS.
SO BACK TO THAT TIME WAS VERY
BIG IMPACT.
CLEAN THE GREEN STREET
[INAUDIBLE]
SO -- IN THE PUBLIC HEARING.
THAT I GAVE A FEW NUMBERS.
AND THIS CAN BE A GOOD EXAMPLE
HOW WE CAN POSSIBLY.
WORK OUT ALL THE CURRENT HAVE TO
TO TO TO CHOI ASIAN.
SO BY THAT TIME I DO FEEL WHICH
TO THE STATE ASSEMBLY IN A
PUBLIC HEARING.
THAT'S WHY EVERY SINGLE DOLLAR.
WE SPENT ON THE SOLAR PANEL THAT
TIME.
ONLY 6% WAS ON BOTH MATERIALS.
21% ON LABOR TO ASSEMBLE THE
SOLAR CELL AND MODULES.
THIS MUCH IS CERTAIN.
PERCENT OF EVERY DOLLAR SPENT BY
OUR TAXPAYERS ON THE SYSTEMS
LATE INSTALLATION SERVICE
WARRANTY.
SO.
BY INCREASING THE THE ATTACKS OR
INPUT WITHOUT TIME ACTUALLY
INCREASE SEVENTY THREE CENTS FOR
EVERY DOLLAR.
TAL TAXPAYERS MOM POCKET.
THEREFORE EVERYBODY BELIEVE.
THAT DECISION WAS VERY
MEANINGLESS.
SO TODAY'S MARCH [INAUDIBLE]
SUGGESTION ORG.
HI TO ALL THE EXPERTS HERE.
IF WE CAN DO IT LISTEN TO
TODAY'S SITUATION.
ON THE IMPORT GO.
IT THAT WE CAN DO AN INTERNAL --
INCREASE THE STATE INCENTIVE
PROGRAM.
LIKE WE DID BACK.
TO TWENTY ELEVEN THAT WE OFFER.
A TO SELL.
THEM.
KLEIMAN ON THE GREEN TICK BUDGET
THAT TIME.
AND SECOND THAT THE CITY.
WHERE I LIVE FOR FORTY FIVE
YEARS SEE THE FREMONT?
THE WAY HE IMMENSELY IMPLEMENT.
HE ALSO CALLED.
ADVANCED MANUFACTURING TO
INCORPORATE THAT SITUATION.
THEREFORE WE DO NOT RELY ON TOO
MUCH RAW MATERIAL OR OR
DELIVERING TENNIS OF ASSEMBLY
BRING STEP WOULD PUT EMPHASIS IS.
ON THE SYSTEM ASSEMBLY
INSTALLATION OTHERS SO THOSE
SOMETHING I SURELY HOPE THAT WE
CAN WORK OUT. TO DEAL WITH THE
SITUATION THANK YOU AGAIN.
THANK YOU ANY COMMENTS ON THE
TAX EXEMPTION.
IN THE OTHER ISSUE THAT CAN WE
MENTION ANY.
FROM A LOCAL LEVEL BABY I CAN
GIVE THE EXAMPLE HOW WE WERE
ABLE TO DO SOME OF THE ISSUES AS
WELL.
WITH KING AND IN TERMS OF AS THE
STATE TERRACE ARE.
AS IN HOW DO WE COUNTED AT IN
LOS ANGELES AND PREVIOUSLY WE
WE'RE HOPING TO BE ABLE TO BRING --
INTERNATIONAL FOREIGN INVESTOR
COMING TO LOS ANGELES BEEN UP
THEIR HEADQUARTERS AND WE'RE
TRYING TO GIVE THEM INCENTIVES
BUT WE CAN'T GIVE IT DIRECTLY TO
JUST ONE COMPANY SO WHAT WE DID
IS WE LOOKED AT THE SECTORS THAT
WE WE WANT TO FOCUS ON WHICH IS
CLEAN TECHNOLOGY.
AND WE WORK WITH THE POOR LOS
ANGELES -- PART OF LONG BEACH
IT'S SPECIFICALLY PART OF LOS IS
WAS ABLE TO REDUCE.
AS FOR ALL -- ZERO ELECTRIC
VEHICLES ARE -- PROCESS THE PORT
LOS ANGELES ONLY THROUGH THEIR
THEIR OWN TAX STRUCTURE SO FROM
A LOCAL LEVEL WAY TO DO THAT
SAID I THINK -- IF WE CAN
PARTNER WITH THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO A BIGGER AND SENSE
OF THAT MIGHT BE HELPFUL BUT NOT
POINT WAS TO COME X. WHICH IS
NEEDED MOVE QUICK SO WE DID AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL -- I'M SURE THAT
YOU KNOW WITH LOS ANGELES CITY
AND LOS ANGELES COUNTY THEY HAVE
SOME MORE RESOURCES AT THEIR
DISPOSAL AND SOME OF THE SMALLER
CITIES AND SMALLER COUNTIES.
I THINK THAT'S WERE PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE STATE IT IS SET UP
CALIFORNIA WILL BE VERY VERY
USEFUL.
GREAT -- ALSO HONORED TO BE TALK
ABOUT MY SAN FRANCISCO
COLLEAGUES SOME OF THEM DAVID
CHIU JUST WANTED.
TO GIVE OPPORTUNITY TO SAY HELLO
[INAUDIBLE]
HELLO -- I WANT.
TO THANK.
MY COLLEAGUE IN THE CHAIR OF
THIS COMMITTEE FOR THE
CONVENIENCE OF ON A WELCOME TO
AND VERY MUCH LOOKS TO
ENGAGEMENT AND HER LEADERSHIP
WHEN IT COMES TO TRADE
[INAUDIBLE]
GEN.
AND AND YOUR SHIP ON THIS AS
WELL AS THE BUSINESS OWNERS WE
HAVE HERE.
MY APOLOGIES FOR BEING LATE I'VE
DRIVEN ABOUT THREE HOURS TODAY
TO GO SPEAK IN ANOTHER PART OF
THE BAY AND COME BACK.
UNDERSTAND MY COLLEAGUES SINCE
YOU ALSO HAD HOURS OF DRIVING
THIS MORNING SO -- HERE WE ARE.
BUT THEN JUST SAY A FEW THOUGHTS
ON ON ON THIS TOPIC -- AS A
CHINESE AMERICAN -- I SHARE THE
PERSPECTIVE.
THAT THE TRAIN AND ECONOMIC
ACTIVITY BETWEEN UNITED STATES
AND CHINA AND CALIFORNIA AND
TRYING TO HAVE BEEN INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT TO OUR ECONOMY TO OUR
COMMUNITIES. TO CONTINUING TO
FOSTER THE KIND OF RELATIONSHIPS
THAT I THINK WE AND AND FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE -- THE TRAIN.
THAT WAS STARTED BY THE OCCUPANT
OF THE WHITE HOUSE WAS VERY
FORTUNATE IN THIS REGARD AND HAS
BEEN HELPFUL I AM OF THE
PERSPECTIVES TRADE WARS.
DO NOT.
HELP ANYONE.
IT TURNS FOLKS AND SECTORS AND
INDUSTRIES AND COMPANIES AND
WORKERS ON BOTH SIDES OF THAT
WAR AND SO.
IT IS.
MY HOPE FROM THIS PARTICULAR
DISCUSSION AND OTHERS IS THAT
THERE ARE GOOD IDEAS THAT ARE
COMING OF WHAT WE CAN DO.
GIANT THE TRAY TAFT DISCUSSION
ON TO KEEP MOVING FORWARD AN
AGENDA THAT MAKES SENSE FOR
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA FOR
CALIFORNIA. FOR TRADE IN GENERAL
AND FOR OUR ECONOMIC ACTIVITY --
THAT WE CAN BE CREATIVE ABOUT IT
AND AND AND I MY HOPE IS THAT AT
SOME POINT IN THE FUTURE.
ASSUME THE TERM SEND -- THAT
CALIFORNIA CAN BE WELL
POSITIONED TO MOVE FOR OUR
ECONOMY ON THAT SO.
I KNOW THERE'S ONLY BEEN GOOD
DISCUSSION ON THAT BUT MY STAFF
HAS BEEN HERE TAKING SOME NOTES
ON HOW WE CAN HELP JUST LOOKING
FORWARD TO TO OUR WORK TOGETHER
ON THIS [INAUDIBLE]
THANK YOU.
WHAT WOULD JUMP BACK TO YOUR
QUESTION ONE SECOND I DID HAVE A
QUESTION TO FOLLOW UP ON?
MR GREENS.
RIGHT WHICH IS REALLY NOT PART
OF OUR DISCUSSION BUT YOU WOULD
AND YOUR CONCERN ABOUT HOW THIS
WOULD IMPACT.
CHINESE AMERICANS NOT CALIFORNIA
BUT REALLY ALL OVER THE U. S. B.
AT ONE POINT FIVE MILLION.
CHINESE AMERICANS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
ANYBODY ELSE WANT.
TO COMMENT ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT
THEY'VE STE IN ANY INCREASE IN
TENSIONS ARE REALLY HAVE AN
IMPACT.
IN OUR COMMUNITY THERE.
WELL I'M AS IT HAPPENS MIGHT
THAT HIGH SCHOOL SON IS HERE AND
HE WAS IN CHINA FOR THREE WEEKS --
THAT UNIVERSITY PROGRAM AS AN
INTERN.
I AND WE HAD A CONVERSATION
BEFORE HE LAUGHED.
TALKING ABOUT.
LEAD THE CHANGE IN THE CLIMATE.
AS A RESULT OF THIS.
DISPUTE AND BEEN IN CHINA A FEW
WEEKS BEFORE AND AS WAS
MENTIONED.
AND WE SPEND A BIT OF TIME I
MEETING AND GREETING PEOPLE ONE
HEARING CALIFORNIA FROM CHURCH
AND OTHERS -- FROM OTHER
COUNTRIES AND THERE IS CHEST.
IT CHANGE IN THE ATMOSPHERE IN
THE CLIENT.
YOU.
FEEL A LITTLE BIT MORE
DEFENSIVENESS ON BOTH SIDES.
YOU FEEL A LITTLE BIT MORE
HOSTILITY.
I AND IT I AGAIN.
YOU HAVE TO ASK FOR WHAT.
BECAUSE AS I'VE NOW SAID SEVERAL
TIMES.
THOUGH THE THREE A ONE
COMPLAINTS AND AND DECISIONS ARE
VERY VERY RECALL.
WE HAVE BEEN OPERATING UNDER THE
FOR ALL BY [INAUDIBLE]
I NOW THAT THE PRESSURE OF THE
TERRACE HAS BEEN CREATED.
IT REALLY BEHOOVES NO. ONE TO
ACCEPT THIS NEW STATUS QUO.
I'M.
GETTING TO SOME KIND OF AGREE
SENATE RESOLUTION.
AT THAT WE CAN QUICKLY GET BACK
TO YOU FRIENDLY FEELINGS.
I'M IS IS VERY VERY IMPORTANT
AND AS I MENTIONED I'M GONNA BE
RUNNING OUT OF HERE AB OR
REGENTS MEETING.
AT PEOPLE ARE SURPRISED TO HEAR
THAT. 10% OF THE STUDENTS
ENROLLED IN THE UC SYSTEM OUR
FOREIGN NATIONALS FROM CHINA.
10%.
I'M NOW WE HAVE A COURSE CHINESE
AMERICANS AND ROLLED IN THE UC
SYSTEM.
OUT THERE AMERICANS THESE
CHINESE NATIONALS WHO HAVE BEEN
COMING HERE HAVE.
I I CREATED AN ENVIRONMENT OF
MUTUAL UNDERSTANDING CULTURAL
EXCHANGE COOPERATION IT'S IT'S A
IT'S A FOUNDATIONAL I THINK WE
HEARD YOU KNOW THE PERSON TO
PERSON EXCHANGES HOW IMPORTANT
FOR MUTUAL UNDERSTANDING.
I'M SO.
I THAT IS SOMETHING I THINK WE
SHOULD ALL BE HEARD ABOUT.
IS REALLY ATTENTION OF TRADE.
THAT TURNS INTO TENSION OVER
OTHER THINGS.
I'M AND AGAIN FOR WHAT I'M WE
KNOW WHERE WE NEED TO GO WE KNOW
WHERE WE NEED TO CATCH.
I'M THE THE AT THE PARTIES HAVE
GOT TO GET BACK TO THE
NEGOTIATING TABLE I AM VERY
HOPEFUL MISTER DEPUTY CONSUL
GENERAL THAT YOU WILL DELIVER
BACK.
TO AT AT TO BEIJING THAT
CALIFORNIA WANTS TO GET BACK TO
YOU I HAVING AN ENVIRONMENT.
SHARED MUTUAL COOPERATION.
IT APPEARS THAT IT WILL REQUIRE
SOME LEVEL OF COMPROMISE --
RESOLUTION OF THE THREE OH ONE
PLANES -- BUT IT IS MOST
CERTAINLY AND ALL OF OUR
INTERESTS FOR A MULTITUDE OF
REASONS NOT LEAST OF WHICH I'M
THE CLIMATE OF FRIENDSHIP.
I THAT WE COME TO SOME KIND OF
IT AND AGREEMENT AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE HAVE ANOTHER QUESTION OVER
THERE IN THE BACK.
ALEX.
ALEX WITH [INAUDIBLE]
SECOND.
THANKS A GERMAN GERMAN TANK
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR FOR THIS
HEARINGS BEEN VERY PRODUCTIVE
AND IN VERY HONEST DISCUSSION.
REALLY APPRECIATE IT -- MY NAME
IS KERR GIBBS.
ACTUALLY FROM THE CENSUS GO BAY
AREA AND LIVING IN CHINA FOR
MOST OF US TWENTY FIVE YEARS OR
SO.
I'M CURRENT THE PRESIDENT OF THE
AMERICAN CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IN
SHANGHAI.
AND ACTUALLY AS LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR DASHES OUT OF THE ROOM
I'M GOING TO MAKE THE FIRST TIME
AT HER SON IS ABSOLUTELY RIGHT
IT'S IS THAT THE THE TENSION
THAT'S BEEN CREATED -- VERY
RECENTLY IS IS MOST DECIDEDLY
NOT HELPFUL AND AND WE WANT TO
PUT A PUT A QUICK STOP TO THAT --
I'LL JUST TELL YOU A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THE AMERICAN CHAMBER WE
REPRESENT -- WE ARE FOUND IN
NINETEEN FIFTEEN IN IN HI AND WE
WERE -- OUR MISSION IS TO
PROMOTE POSITIVE COMMERCIAL TIES
BETWEEN UNITED STATES AND CHINA
OBVIOUSLY THAT'S A VERY
CHALLENGING -- ENDEAVOR RIGHT
NOW WE REPRESENT WE CURRENTLY
REPRESENT ABOUT THREE THOUSAND
MEMBERS IN IN SHANGHAI THESE ARE
AMERICAN COMPANIES THAT ARE.
THAT ARE -- IN CHINA OF DOING
BUSINESS FOR THE MOST PART
THEY'RE ACTUALLY VERY SUCCESSFUL
AND AND IT'S SOMETHING THAT THE
HEADLINES DON'T NECESSARILY
CAPTURE -- BUT THE MOST OF OUR
MEMBERS ARE PROFITABLE THEY ARE
GROWING.
AND THEIR CONTINUE TO INVEST I
DO WANT TO ADDRESS A COUPLE
THOUGHTS -- BEGIN W. CHART --
CONSUL GENERAL RAN YOU FOR
TOLERATING MY COMMENTS THE OTHER
DAY AND AND AND COMPLAINTS --
BUT AGAIN -- THE GOVERNOR'S
CORRECT IN THAT THIS ISSUE IS
ABOUT RECIPROCITY AND AND AND
CALL GENERAL YOU ARE CORRECT
ABOUT.
THE RELATIONSHIP IS SHIFTED MUCH
MORE TO SERVICES AND AND THAT
HAS -- BEEN REFLECTED IN OUR
MEMBERSHIP SHIFTING FROM
MANUFACTURING OVER TO SERVICES.
ASIAN SHIP DOES HAVE TO BE
RECIPROCAL -- I THINK THAT -- AB
CPAS TAKE EXAMPLE WHILE BROUGHT
FORWARD -- BY MR GREEN WAS ABOUT
OF ELECTRONIC PAYMENTS IN A
SPECIFIC EXAMPLE THAT REFLECTS
RIGHT HERE A FORM YOUR PAYPAL.
SO PAYPAL ABOUT FIFTEEN YEARS
AGO AFTER THE CHINA MARKET FULLY
EXPECTING TO TO ENJOY BY.
RAMP UP ANY COMMERCE WITH CHINA.
AFTER FIFTEEN YEARS WE'RE NEVER
GRANTED A DOMESTIC LICENSE TO DO
ARM BE TRANSACTIONS WITHIN CHINA.
OUR TWENTY NINETEEN OF ALL THE
PAY WE CHECK A ARE ENTERING
CALIFORNIA ENTERING UNITED
STATES WE WELCOME THAT
ABSOLUTELY A GOOD THING.
BUT IT'S A GLARING EXAMPLE OF OF
LACK OF RECIPROCITY.
I THINK CHINA WOULD DO WELL. TO
LOOK AT SOME OF THOSE PS
EXAMPLES AND WHAT I WOULD.
CONSIDER LOW HANGING FRUIT --
PAYPAL TRONIC PAYMENTS VISA.
THE THINGS THAT -- THEY CAN
ABSOLUTELY BE DONE.
BUT BUT BOTTOM LINE -- WE HAVE A
LOT OF RECOMMENDATIONS -- FOR
THE UNITED STATES GOVERNMENT IN
TERMS OF HOW THEY'RE MATTER IN
THIS THIS TRADE CONFLICT.
OF WE AGREE WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION THAT IT DOES NEED
A ROOT OF TO BE REBALANCED.
WE DON'T AGREE WITH WITH THE WAY
THAT IT'S BEING DONE -- THE
TERRORISTS.
THE TERRORISTS AND THE WAY THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION IS HANDLING
THIS THIS IS NOT PRODUCTIVE.
DRAGGING THIS ON FAR TOO LONG
TERRORISTS DON'T HELP YOU.
ONE AND WE'RE THERE IS DANGER OF
UP DAMAGING.
OF PERMANENTLY DAMAGING A
RELATIONSHIP THAT HAS BEEN
EXTREMELY PRODUCTIVE FOR THE
LAST FORTY YEARS.
BOTH FOR THE STATE'S AND FOR
CHINA WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE A UP
A QUICK RESOLUTION TO TO THE
CURRENT CONFLICT THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR HAVING THIS VERY PRODUCTIVE
SO I DID I DID HAVE ONE QUESTION.
FOR FOR FOR YOU SINCE YOU
MENTIONED THE WHOLE ELECTRONIC
PAYMENT ISSUE I NOTICED WHEN I
WAS IN CHINA LAST TO SEE HER.
AS A TOURIST HOW.
HOW FEW PEOPLE ACTUALLY TO CASH?
IT WAS WEIRD TO PRESCRIBE LIKE I
I CAN'T GET THE PAY -- USE
CHAPTER PAYS SO WE'RE FOR
TOURISM HAVE YOU SEEN OR HAVE
YOU HEARD COMPLAINTS FOR FOR
TOURISTS.
I FIGURE OUT HOW DO YOU BUY
THINGS HOW DO YOU PAY FOR THINGS.
YEAH WE HAVE A BE THAT THAT IS
SO THAT IS A COMMON COMPLAINT TO
THINK CHINA IS.
IS BECOMING MUCH MORE INWARD
LOOKING AT THIS IS A POLITICAL
QUESTION IT'S A DOMESTIC ISSUE
WITHIN CHINA THAT THAT THEY NEED
TO RESOLVE.
AND THEY NEED TO FIGURE OUT
EXACTLY HOW TIGHTLY INTEGRATED
THEY WANT TO BE.
WITH THE REST OF THE GLOBAL
COMMUNITY BUT YOU'RE RIGHT THAT --
IT IS DIFFICULT FOR TOURISTS AND
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT FOR FOREIGN
BUSINESSES OPERATING IN CHINA
HAVING SAID THAT -- I WOULD ADD
JUST A LITTLE BIT OF NEW WANTS
TO WHAT THE LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR
AND HER SON OF MENTIONED ABOUT
ABOUT THE MOOD IN CHINA WITH
RESPECT TO AMERICAN BUSINESSES
THERE.
OVERALL ESPECIALLY AT THE LAW
SCHOOL THE MUNICIPAL LEVEL AND
PROVINCIAL LEVEL THE GOVERNMENT
IS ACTUALLY VERY VERY WELCOMING
OF AMERICAN BUSINESSES AND
AMERICAN INVESTMENT.
THE CONFLICT IS REALLY AT THE
BEIJING WASHINGTON LEVEL AND SO
THAT'S THAT'S REALLY PROBLEMATIC
SECOND -- THE MOOD VERY MUCH
SHIFTED POST WHILE WAY -- THE
MOOD EARLIER SO IN OTHER WORDS
THIS NEGATIVE SENTIMENT THAT THE
TENANT GOVERNOR MENTIONED. FOR
TWO WAS -- DID NOT START AT THE
BEGINNING OF THIS THE SO CALLED
TRADE WAR IT STARTED.
MUCH MORE POST.
A TENTH AFTER THE WALK AWAY AND
CERTAINLY AFTER THE RESTORATION
PUT AWAY ON THE END LIST.
BEFORE THAT.
I WOULD SAY THAT THAT WE HAD
QUITE A LOT OF SUPPORT.
THE CHINESE PEOPLE FOR
LEGITIMATE REFORM WITHIN CHINA
THAT WAS PROMPTED BY A
REBALANCING OF THE RELATIONSHIP
MOST PEOPLE MIGHT MY CHINESE
FRIENDS AND COLLEAGUES IN PEOPLE
THAT I INTERACT WITH.
AND EVEN AT THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
LEVEL WE'RE ACTUALLY SUPPORT OF
A REBALANCING OF THE
RELATIONSHIP THAT ENTIRELY
SHIFTED AFTER -- WHILE WE WERE
PLACED ON ENTITIES LIST.
BECAUSE THERE'S A VERY DIFFERENT
THERE ARE TWO DIFFERENT THINGS
WHEN YOU LOOK AT WHILE WAY IN
THE NATIONAL SECURITY ISSUE ONE
IS.
MAKING A LEGITIMATE NATIONAL
SECURITY DECISION. TO TO
RESTRICT WHAT PRODUCTS AND
TECHNOLOGIES ARE EMBEDDED IN OUR
TELECOMMUNICATIONS
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT'S ONE
QUESTION.
THE SECOND QUESTION IS AN
EXISTENTIAL QUESTION ABOUT
SHOULD WE ALLOW ONE WAY TO EVEN
EXIST.
AND BY PLACING IT ON THE
ENTITIES LIST AND DOING IT IN
SUCH SUCH AN OF AN AFFRONT.
IN IN SUCH A WAY THAT WAS SO
ABRUPT AND FRANKLY ROUTE.
IT REALLY IT IT SHOWED THE
CHINESE PEOPLE THAT THE UNITED
STATES GOVERNMENT WAS ACTUALLY
POSITIONING ITSELF AS AN ENEMY.
AND WANTED TO DESTROY.
A LEGITIMATE COMPANY THAT
OPERATING WITHIN CHINA.
AND AGAIN THOSE ARE TWO VERY
DIFFERENT THINGS ONCE A NATIONAL
SECURITY QUESTION AND ONE IS
ATTACKING A COMPANY AND ITS VERY
EXISTENCE.
GREAT THANK YOU I KNOW THIS
GENTLEMAN HAD A QUESTION OVER
HERE -- IT WAS A LITTLE TOO
POLITE TO SAY THAT THE WHAT I'M
ABOUT TO SAY AND THAT IS THAT
WE'RE GOING TO SEE WHO YOU ARE
YOUR NAME AND CAN PATROL.
AMERICAN CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IN
SHANGHAI I WOULD ENDORSE WHAT
WAS SAID EARLIER BY DARLENE AND
STEPHEN IN THE IDEA THAT MIDDLE
MARKET COMPANIES IN CALIFORNIA
HAVE A LOT OF RESOURCES -- THAT
THEY CAN UTILIZE TO HELP THEM
DEVELOP A BUSINESS IN CHINA AND
THE AMERICAN CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN SHANGHAI IS SOMEONE THERE ON
THE GROUND AS WELL SO I WOULD
ONLY COMMENT THAT -- THERE ARE
RESOURCES THAT ARE VERY FOR TO
HELP COMPANIES NAVIGATE.
GOING ON CHINA TODAY GREAT THANK
YOU
.
OKAY.
MY NAME IS JEREMY PUNISHMENT
WITH THE CALIFORNIA IS A
BUSINESS COUNCIL.
AS WELL OF THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT EXPORT CAM.
I SERVE ON ALAMEDA COUNTY -- ET
A NATIONAL CHECK.
I ONLY HEARD ABOUT THIS.
SESSION YESTERDAY WHAT A GOOD
FRIEND SENT ME INFORMATION ABOUT
IT.
AND I SUSPECT THAT SHE WOULD
HAVE HAD A MUCH LARGER ATTENTION.
THE ATTENDANTS HAD THERE BEEN A
GREATER DISTRIBUTION OF
INFORMATION THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT SESSION.
AND YOUR SPEAKERS ARE EXCELLENT.
AND I LOOKED ON THE WEBSITE
YESTERDAY BECAUSE THEY WANT TO
SEND OUT THE THAT WASN'T A LINK
TO THIS MEETING -- SO PLEASE --
I REALLY APPRECIATE THIS
OPPORTUNITY THIS SESSION.
BUT WE'VE HEARD HOW IMPORTANT IS
TO COMMUNICATE TO GET THE WORD
OUT SO FIRST THING ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TING -- PLEASE --
DISSEMINATE INFORMATION MORE
BROADLY MAKE IT MORE ACCESSIBLE.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT KIND OF OUT
REACH YOU COULD EMPLOY BUT I
REALLY HOPE THAT YOU DO SO
BECAUSE OF THE VALUE -- OF THIS
KIND OF A SESSION THIS ROOM
COULD HAVE BEEN FILLED
BUSINESSES WHO HAD THINGS TO
TELL YOU.
SO -- THAT'S THAT'S ONE ITEM AND
TO I'VE BEEN HEARING TODAY ABOUT
SEVERAL INITIATIVES AROUND THE
STATE.
VZV CHINA.
IS ARE GOING TO BE ANY KIND OF
CENTRAL INFORMATION.
AT CENTRAL PLACE OF WITH THESE
ARE GOING TO BE.
WORKING TOGETHER OR THAT WE ALL
KNOW AROUND THE STATE WHAT THESE
VARIOUS INITIATIVES ARE BECAUSE
AS STANDALONE.
THAT WOULD BE GREAT FOR LA.
SAN FRANCISCO MILL PIZZAS -- SAN
DIEGO.
ABOUT WHAT ABOUT FOR THE STATE --
BETTER THAT WE'RE ALL WORKING ON
THE SAME PAGE A COMMUNICATING
AGAIN IT HAS EVERYTHING TO DO
WITH COMMUNICATION.
AND I I CAN'T.
AGREE MORE WITH THIS WHOLE
CONCEPT THAT WE NEED BETTER.
COMMUNICATION AND WE HEARD ABOUT
THE THE SENATE GOVERNOR -- STEP
UP TO THE PLATE TALK ABOUT YOUR
COMPLAINTS.
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN WITH
THOSE COMPLAINTS WHEN YOU STEP
UP.
WHAT KINDS OF?
RESULT WILL RAISE.
WILL TAKE PLACE -- WHAT IS THE
MECHANISM?
BECAUSE THERE'S A LOT TO SAY.
A AND BUT WE CAN ALL SPEAKING
JUNE ECHO CHAMBER.
SO PLEASE USE THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO HELP DEVELOP SOME OF THE
ESTIMATES NECESSARY. TO TAKE
THIS TO ANOTHER LEVEL LEVEL
BECAUSE CLEARLY -- AS WE'RE
HEARING FROM PEOPLE ON THE
GROUND IT'S GOING TO BE
IMPORTANT AND ALL STOP WITH ONE
COMMENT I WAS JUST INCLUDING.
AND I VISITED THE COMING WEATHER
MUSEUMS AND WE TAKE A TAXI OUT
THERE AND THEN WE WERE STUMBLING
HOW WE CAN GET BACK.
AND SO WE WENT TO THE COUNTER
AND SPOKE TO MONEY
ADMINISTRATORS THERE.
AND SHE PICKED UP HER PHONE AND
SHE DIALED THE LOCAL EQUIVALENT
OF UBER.
AND TOLD ME HOW MUCH IT WAS
GOING TO BE I GAVE HER THE MONEY
WAITED FOR THE CAR LIFE WAS GOOD --
I HAD A VERY DIFFERENT.
I HAVE EXPERIENCE I THINK BUT I
WAS JUST IN YOUR NONE.
AND CONVEYING AND ALL OVER AND
THE LEVEL OF EXPERIENCE AND
INTERACTION.
MAYBE BECAUSE NEWS MAY TAKE A
LITTLE LATER TO GET THERE.
BUT FABULOUS -- INTERACTION IS
BY THE FACT THAT I WAS AN
AMERICAN THANK YOU.
I THANK YOU THANK YOU IN -- SHIP
ONE DO YOU YOU COMMITTED DATE
APPRECIATE YOUR FEEDBACK AGAIN
WE ARE.
SELECT COMMITTEE WHICH MEANS
THAT -- WE ARE AN AD HOC THE
THAT DOESN'T NEED.
REGULARLY SO WE NEED WHEN WE
HOLD HEARINGS.
AND WE DO TRY TO DO AS MUCH OUT
RICH AS POSSIBLE SO FEEL FREE
FREE TO ADD.
OUR MAILING LIST AND WE'LL TRY
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE GET OUT
MORE INFORMATION.
SOONER AS LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR
MENTIONED WE DID HAVE A TRADE
AND COMMERCE OFFICE BEFORE WITH
MANY OFFICES AROUND THE WORLD
UNFORTUNATELY THOSE OFFICE THAT
OFFICE IN SACRAMENTO BUT ALSO
THOSE OFFICES AROUND THE WORLD
WILL CLOSE IN TWO THOUSAND AND
FOUR SO WE REALLY.
HAVE NOT READ CREATED THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE -- TELL NOW AND
WE'RE JUST STARTING TO BUILD A
LITTLE BIT OF THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE OUT OF OUR
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT OFFICE OF
THE TEN THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE.
SO SHE ABSOLUTE THIS YEAR IS
WHICH IS ASKING FOR YOUR
FEEDBACK FOR YOUR COMPLAINTS.
HAVING SAID THAT WE'VE ALL BEEN
TALKING FOR THE LAST HOUR THAT.
THE STATE DOES NOT SET TRADE
POLICY.
SO.
IF YOU COMPLAINTS ABOUT THE
TERRACE WHICH WE ARE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT.
WE DON'T DIRECTLY IMPACT THAT
THAT WE CAN BE.
AS AS ANY AMERICAN CAN WE CAN
EXPRESS OUR VIEWPOINTS OUR
VANTAGE POINTS IN AND LET THAT
BE KNOWN OF WHY WE DISAGREE WITH
THAT.
BUT HAVING SAID THAT I THINK
THAT'S WHAT THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
CONVENING IS WHAT OTHER
ALTERNATIVES CAN CAN WE DO IS.
AS WELL AS YOU KNOW -- THIS YOU
KNOW MATT MERELY HERE HAD A VERY
CREATIVE IDEAS I THINK THOSE ARE
THE KIND OF THINGS THAT WE ARE
LOOKING AT AND WOULD DEFINITELY
EXPLORE.
SO THIS GENTLEMAN HAD A QUESTION
HERE.
HI MY NAME IS DAVID ISSUE I'M IN
THE PRESIDENT OF COLORFUL.
THE CONSOLE FOR NORTH
CALIFORNIA'S CENTRAL OF FILTH.
OKAY AND AMERICA AND ITS CANNOT
USE THE MULTI. TO A COUNTRY IN
THE WHOLE WORK.
IN A POT YEARS.
NOT TO A CONSCIOUS OF A VERY
REDUCING SHIP.
IN IT IN A COUNTRY ON THE PEOPLE.
OF THE WORLD SENATE CHEN WORLD
AND WE CAN SEE THE MORE MENACING
BUT IT CHANGED.
AND BEFORE YOU GO TO THE
INTERNET YOU CAN MINUTES FINING
PEOPLE THE LATIN AMERICAN LOCKER
AMERICAN PEOPLE LIVE ON THE
COMING HERE COME START WITHOUT
IT.
TOOK HIM AWHILE.
UNTIL YOU AGREE HERE BOB RANDALL
YOU'RE GOING TO PUT THE YOU
POINT NÂNG.
AT THE UNIT YEAH I THINK MANY
THE CHANCE MANY CHANCES THE
YOUNG PEOPLE OUT THERE THINK
AMERICA YOU.
THAT ENEMY.
OKAY.
I UNDERSTAND WITH THE AND THERE
ARE.
OKAY ON FIFTH AND ON KOBE'S SO
AWFUL CALIFORNIA.
OTHER JEDI YEAH A GROUP OF
MEDICINES SHIP IN A CALIFORNIANS
HANNAH.
BOTH OF YOU A US IT REACHED KIND
OF A VERY GOOD RELATIONSHIP.
OKAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
OTHER COMMENTS FROM THE PUBLIC
OR HERE.
MY NAME IS LEASING ÓNG VICE
PRESIDENT OF OF CALIFORNIA
INSTITUTE OF INTEGRAL STUDIES.
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF AMERICAN
COLLEGE OF TRADITIONAL TEN
MEDICINE.
AT SAN FRANCISCO -- I SIMPLY
WANT TO BRING OUT THIS ISSUE --
YOU KNOW IN TERMS OF EDUCATION.
THIS.
WILL COME HERE TO STUDY SHORT OR
LONG TERM VISA BECAME A VERY BIG
CHALLENGE.
US REJECTED OUR EMBASSY 6270%
OFF QUALIFIED APPLICANTS. TO
COME HERE STUDY.
AND ONE OF MY EMPLOYEES IN THE
OFFICE.
BEING OUT IN BEIJING FOR NOW
OVER TWO MONTHS BEING SEPARATED
FROM HER FIVE YEAR OLD SON.
WHO HAS THE LEGAL WORKING VISA
BUT WITH NO REASON BEING CHAPPED
UNDER THAN NOT BEING ABLE TO GET
BACK?
AND I JUST WANT TO BRING THIS
OUT TO STAY IF WE TALK ABOUT.
FAIR TRADE EDUCATION IS OBVIOUS.
NOT ENOUGH THEIR SITUATION.
CHINA WOULD ALLOW ANY STUDENTS
GOING THERE TO VISIT ALL TO
STUDY US REJECT PEOPLE COMING
HERE. FOR LISA ISSUE.
AND THEN I REALLY ASK YOU TO
BRING THIS.
INTO CONSIDERATION THANK YOU
GREAT THANK YOU [INAUDIBLE]
ANY OTHER.
ANY OTHER COMMENT.
SO I WAS GOING TO JUST JUST COME
BACK TO THE PANEL FOR ANY --
FINAL THOUGHTS OR REALLY NEXT
STEPS REALLY APPRECIATE ALL THE
ALL THE WAY THAT EVERYONE'S
DOING AS WELL AS EVERYTHING THAT
BLUFF SAT.
ON THE ONE POINT I'VE.
DIDN'T MENTION -- RUNNING YOUR
COMMON AROUND THE STATE IS --
AGAIN YOUR THAT MUCH OF WHAT YOU
SEEN IT.
BECAUSE THE STATE POLICE STOPPED
DOING THE SCORE LOCKS HAD NO ON
THEIR OWN TO REALLY -- RECREATE
OR TO DO ALL UP.
ON THAT -- WORK ON A ON A LOCAL
LEVEL.
THE OTHER SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
AREA.
AGAIN.
I THINK.
THE THAT IS THAT NOW THAT THE TO
REALLY BE INVESTING IN THAT KIND
OF WORK THERE IS SIGNIFICANT
STRUCTURE THAT WE CAN LEVERAGE.
HELLO SO I'M JUST BACK TO THE
PAN.
ON WHAT WHAT EXTENT DO YOU THINK
WILL BE.
LOOKING AT WE CAN MAKE IT A VERY
EFFECTIVE WAY TO SUPPORT THE
WORK WE'RE DOING.
REALLY -- HE SENT A STRONGER
SIGNAL TO CHINA ABOUT HOW HOW
IMPORTANT THIS ECONOMIC RICHEST
BEST.
ANYBODY CAN JUMP AT WORK ON OUT
OF JAPAN FOR SO I THINK THAT A
LOT RESOURCES THE HUGE CONCERN
FOR US AS WELL -- ABSOLUTELY WE
WE FEEL IN THE LOCAL LEVEL THAT --
WHEN THE?
CALIFORNIA TRADE OFFICES ON THE
WORLD WAR WERE SHUT DOWN WE
DON'T HAVE AS MUCH REPRESENTS
ATION AND WHEN WE GO TO TRADE
SHOWS AROUND THE WORLD AND EVEN
IN DC FOR LIKE YOU TO SAY. TO
SEE TAXES THERE WHEN A WITH A
STAFF OF THIRTY FIVE
INTERNATIONAL SPECIALISTS ARE
EIGHT FOUR BY THE STATE'S
[INAUDIBLE]
EVEN MAIN.
AND THEN FOR CALIFORNIA TO NOT
HAVE THE SAME RESOURCES IT
BECOMES A BIT CHALLENGING.
FOR THE LOCAL ALARM OR WERE
STEPPING UP IT JUST SAYS CONTACT --
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY REGION
AGAIN LET'S JUST COUNTY HAS TEN
TWO MILLION PEOPLE LIVING THERE
AND TO BE HONEST WITH YOU -- THE
STOP DEDICATED INTERNATIONAL
TRADE OUR PROMOTION AND THE WORK
THAT WE DO.
IS THE REALLY LESSEN THE HANDFUL.
SOME FIVE PEOPLE LOOKING FOR TEN
POINT TWO MILLION AS A HUGE
BUNCH WINNER SAID THAT THE STATE
YOU KNOW AS WE'RE GOING TO THE
BUDGET -- KIND OF ALLOCATION IS
NOT ALWAYS CAN BE NOBLE BECAUSE
THERE'S SO MANY DIFFERENT ISSUES
WITH THE DEAL WELL I THINK WILL
BE FANTASTIC AS ARE ALL LIKE THE
FACIALS AND LEADERSHIP TO
ENCOURAGE PRIVATE SECTOR TO STEP
UP.
BECAUSE IT.
PROFITS ARE STEPPING UP TO DO
THE WORK WE NEED THE THE PRIVATE
SECTOR TO SUPPORT OUR WORK AS
WELL AS PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIP BECAUSE EVENTUALLY.
THE BUSINESS THAT WE BRING IN
THIS ACT AND THE PRIVATE SECTOR
SO I THINK THAT'S A KEY.
PLUS IS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
GOVERNMENT -- TO TO HELP US WITH
WITH -- ENCOURAGING PRIVATE
SECTOR TO TO SUPPORT US
FINANCIALLY AS WELL AS WHAT THE
WHAT CONNECTIONS AS WELL.
I TOTALLY ECHO STEVEN SAYS I
THINK OF BECAUSE WE ARE PUBLIC
PRIVATE PARTNERSHIPS AND AFTER
NONPROFIT IS IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT EVEN THOUGH WE DO HAVE
THE SUPPORT FOR EXAMPLE OF
YOURSELF.
AND THE CITY OF SAN FRANCISCO
AND NOW EVEN ON THE STATE LEVEL
BUT IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT TO KNOW
OF FOR THE PRIVATE SECTOR TO SET.
HEY THEY HAVE SKIN IN THE GAME
TO BECAUSE AT THE END OF THE DAY
THAT WORK THAT WE DO BENEFITS
THAT.
MORE THAN ANYONE ELSE
[INAUDIBLE]
GREAT THIS.
SCREENER THAT CONSIDER NINETY
CUT ANY CLOSING COMMENTS.
WHAT'S.
I IN THE SAME BOAT ONE POINT OF
SEVEN BILLION US PEOPLE ON
CHINESE PEOPLE WE HAVE ONE
BILLION MALL THAT MEANS OF THE
THE BIG MARKET FOR EVERYBODY WE
WILL ACCEPT.
SUGGESTIONS TO CONSTRUCT.
TO THE SUGGESTIONS TO AND ALSO
PRETTY SEES THEM.
WE ARE OPEN MONDAY. TO WORKS
BASED CALIFORNIA WITH YOU ASKED.
GREAT THANK YOU CHINA GET THE
OPPORTUNITY TO EVERYBODY.
THANK YOU ARE WE JUST BEEN
JOINED BY JOHN WITH OUR AREA
COUNCIL.
WE WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT.
COM WHAT CAN OF FORMULA.
IN SHOULD BE DOING IN TERMS OF
MAINTAINING A VERY STRONG.
ECONOMIC RELATIONSHIP WITH CHINA
I KNOW.
YOU IN THE BEAR COUNSEL CAN WORK
ON THAT FOR AWHILE IF YOU WANT.
TO TALK ABOUT WHAT DO YOU THINK.
THEY COULD -- COULD BE DOING IN
LIGHT OF EVERYTHING THAT'S GONE
WITH THE TRADE WAR.
THANKS FOR ALSO.
FIRST OF ALL MY APOLOGIES FOR
BEING SO LATE FOR TODAY -- AND
APPRECIATE THE CHANCE TO BE HERE.
YOU KNOW WE'VE SEEN IS THAT THAT
IN THAT TROUBLES THAT HAVE
HAPPENED -- ON THE NATIONAL
LEVEL THE SUB NATIONAL LEVEL
YOU'VE PROBABLY COVERED THIS
ALREADY -- BUT HAVE REALLY --
IT'S OPEN UP SOME DOORS FOR US --
AS A STATE FOR CALIFORNIA.
AND PARTICULAR I WOULD POINT TO
THE THE C. I. E. IT'S A CHINA
INTERNATIONAL IMPORT EXPO --
WHICH YEAH I GUESS YOU'VE
ALREADY COVERED THIS AT BY JOHN
NOT NOT IT DID BUT I WON I I'D
LIKE TO REINFORCE IT.
AND THEN -- THAT ABOUT.
I THINK IS ABOUT FIFTY FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS WORTH OF GOODS
WERE PURCHASED LAST YEAR -- IT'S
HAPPENING AGAIN THIS YEAR -- AND
THIS IS A BIG OPPORTUNITY FOR
CALIFORNIA.
FOR THE MAKERS OF GOODS --
MARKER CULTURAL PRODUCTS AND ALL
THE OTHER THINGS WE MAKE BUT
ALSO -- SERVICES -- WHETHER TO
COUNTY IN ARCHITECTURE FIRMS --
END IS A MATTER OF FACT --
CALIFORNIA HAS A A BOOTH AT THIS
EVENT -- I THINK THEY WERE
SOMEWHERE AROUND FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND PURCHASERS THAT
ATTENDED THIS EVENT -- AND SO.
WHILE THERE ARE THESE TROUBLE --
BUT ANYWAY SO THIS HAPPENS IN
NOVEMBER.
AND THE CHINA HAS GIVEN
CALIFORNIA HUGE PROMINENCE -- IN
THIS EVENT.
AND SO YOU KNOW I WOULD SAY
THANK YOU -- FOR FOR THAT.
THE HAND THAT HAS BEEN EXTENDED
TO US.
I'M IN THAT WHILE THEY'RE THERE
ARE DIFFICULTIES ON THE NATIONAL
LEVEL I THINK THIS IS ACTUALLY A
CHANCE FOR CALIFORNIA TO REALLY
GET IN THERE -- AND ADVANCE
OURSELVES AND WE'VE WE'VE RUN A
WHOLE BUNCH OF DIFFERENT
DELEGATIONS ABOUT SIXTY
DELEGATIONS OVER OVER THE YEARS --
AND WE DON'T SEE THAT ABATING --
AND SO IN OUR OWN EXPERIENCE
WITH OUR MEMBER COMPANIES WE
HAVE. THREE ON TWENTY FIVE
MEMBER COMPANIES AND THE BAY
AREA -- THAT DID THE APPETITE
FOR TRADE WITH CHINA AS IT IS
STILL GROWING [INAUDIBLE]
NOT DECLINING [INAUDIBLE]
GREAT THANK.
IT AGAIN REALLY APPRECIATE ALL
ALL YOUR WORK ARM IN.
A MEMBER COMPANIES WORK TO BE
CAN YOU TO BUILD THAT
RELATIONSHIP I THINK.
ON YOU FINISH ON A VERY STRONG
NOTE WHICH IS.
WALL THERE IS CHALLENGING LATER
SHIPPED AT THE BEIJING
WASHINGTON LEVEL THERE'S
DEFINITE OPPORTUNITY FOR US IN
CALIFORNIA AND I THINK -- FROM
OUR LEADERSHIP WE'VE
CONSISTENTLY SIGNALED.
TALKED ABOUT THE NEED FOR A
STRONG RELATIONSHIP CHINA AND
FRANKLY HIGHLIGHTED MUCH OF THE
ECONOMIC OPEN THAT'S GOING ON
BETWEEN THE TWO COUNTRIES SO.
AGAIN WE REALLY APPRECIATE ONE
ALL THE PANELISTS FOR IT FOR
TWENTY US REALLY APPRECIATE ALL
THE AUDIENCE FOR COMING IN.
IF YOU'RE INTERESTED IN GETTING
MORE INFORMATION FOR OUR FUTURE
HEARINGS PLEASE SIGN UP ON THE
MAILING LIST THAT'S THE SIGN IN
SHEET WHEN YOU FIRST COME IN SO
WE CAN MAKE SURE.
WE CAN GET YOU THE INFORMATION
OUT EARLIER AND LET YOU KNOW
ABOUT THIS BUT THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR FOR JOINING US TODAY